I heard you guys ribbon last time
citizens of the reject Nation if
we are live you know what to do
leave a like leave a like leave a like that's
what you got to do to let us know you we are
live here right now like for live like live
like for the live leave a like for live it's
been a while since John and I were doing this
if I'm gonna get this out of the way right now
I need to take a crap I don't know I'll hold
the stream down while you go answer the call
Ghostbusters 2016. um oh hold on uh yeah I wanted
to uh mention that people might be going where's
koi where's koi genre well koi I would like him
to take over this segment one day for just MCU
and DCU that's that that's the goal um however
it's just funny because it's the weekend where
we're getting a secret Invasion trailer and the
next day we're getting a spider-verse trailer and
then we're getting a Blue Beetle trailer that
same day we're getting three comic book movie
trailers and there's a bunch of movie news and
Coy's out of town it's like the prime weekend
and he's just away doing panels yeah yeah it's
he's a way doing panels and make it come he's
hosting some major major panels some Mega
panels so yeah man it's a maker con panels
maybe he's bumping into 3C films over there uh
so yeah he's not here with us today and it's so
John you got to be the new you got to be coy
you got to have the knowledge okay rejection
okay rejected my veins are popping out of my
forehead let's drink like 10g fuels and I just
did like four you know upper body workouts
before coming here on rated talk Comics
um so yeah all right we got a good amount of
people in the chat uh we got 267 viewers right
now yeah Maria and Hammond gave me this thing but
we got a few things to talk about that we know we
want to talk about but as per usual you know we
will eventually get to just opening up the chat
q a because there's always so much more that we
didn't even consider talking about it's going to
be guided by you folks in the chat the reject
Nation out there it is one of our best ways to
connect with the community engaged engaged with
your audience right is how you do this so quick
shout outs to Greg Elijah Ashley Ann and I see
dude we do have a super chat here from povin Meyer
um I want to say also really quick thank you to
everyone who super chatted us last live stream and
also contribute to our stream Labs we got so much
last time it kept us live for much longer than we
had planned to and we know what we love when
a situation like that occurs so thank you guys
so much your support means a lot John you decide
today since you are the new koi good um what is
the first thing that we should discuss I'm gonna
while I rearrange this I mean should we take this
first Super Chat as it is part of the the headline
of news that has been compiled for this very live
stream I feel like it's a perfect kickoff all
right sure let's read that first Super Chat head
up povin Meyer povin Meyer thanks to povin Meyer
yes what does he say John while I rearrange life
here povin Meyer says Doug Jones for clay phase
but it's not like the comics elaborate disguises
instead of the more sci-fi a version that would
be an intro I mean Doug Jones for any kind of
creature or or just like heavy prosthetic or
effects Laden character is always like a a great
choice I'm curious about the idea I don't know
see that's the thing is I feel like you have to
have some kind of body horror-ish element or some
kind of like physical John we gotta start we gotta
rewind all right let's explain what's going on you
know just start talking you're the structure what
kind of koi are you I am the color commentary if
you are the main commentator that's why you throw
to yourself first uh okay so Batman 2 there's
been heavy uh speculation rumors and whatnot
that Clayface will be a prominent figure in the
upcoming sequel to Matt Reeves is the Batman and
thus povin Meyer is now speculating as to who
could play said Clayface in this movie through
that son and uh yeah I think Doug Jones again as
I said it a moment ago would be a terrific choice
I am curious as to what the chat would think of
a uh yeah a disguise Master rather than a person
who's you know whole face and and body or you know
like malleable like clay yeah I feel like there is
something that you could do in the tradition
of various film Noir and I think Sin City has
already capitalized this on the sort of like you
know I changed my face to start a new life but
even more like I feel like there's still some room
for Fantasy in Matt Reeves world even though it is
much more real and grounded so I I feel like they
could come up with something gross and unsettling
for Clayface but I feel like costuming like just
disguises might be a little too simplified almost
yeah yeah so Clayface did you go through about
I was making some notes Here I was half paying
attention I want to go back and make like basic
chapters for this live stream for the playback so
leave a like that helps with the playback uh did
you go over like a little bit of who clay faces
No No I want you you know that you have a much
more comprehensive I mean the basic version of
Clayface well there's two versions one I didn't
actually know about until yesterday which was the
original version of clay phase I didn't I thought
it was always what I grew up with via Comics via
Batman the Animated Series via the Arkham games
I I always thought it was actor and it was a
play on the fact that uh he the scientific [__]
happens and then Clayface can molt so it was and
but in the original version of of Clayface like
the very OG version he was an actor who did not
get recap who did not get to reprise a role for
a remake that was being made of his film and so
he became clay face the villain which was just
like a bad guy just a normal bad guy now there's
this like Metamorphosis quality to him where he
can literally full on imitate people and I think
you know it would be interesting to get two clay
faces because we have the rumor that Mike Flanagan
and Mike Flanagan didn't exactly debunk this it
seemed that he was kind of putting it out there
Mike Flanagan who made Haunting of Hill House
uh hunting a blind Manor and uh midnight mass
have you seen that yet you son of a [__] one
of my favorite writer directors working today
and supposedly he pitched like a Clayface movie
and I think he could do that tragic Fantastical
quality very well then you could also see Clayface
working within the main chapter one of Gods and
Monsters where it is like something in the Batman
brave in the Bold universe that does go that far
it doesn't excite me at the prospect of not ha
of Clayface just being like a regular Thief it
doesn't excite me as as being just a regular
bad guy or a mess like I liked what they did
with Riddler but it still felt enough like
Riddler with the riddling happening in the
film yeah with Clayface I think it's just
such a trademark quality of him now that
I don't know you might as well just make him
like chameleon which is a Spider-Man villain
chameleon instead of just getting a chance to
be clay face you know I feel like you could
probably blend the two takes the two Origins
for the character together in some sense you
know you can make you know some kind of spiraling
out from you know the actor into something greater
and something more crime oriented yeah oh my God
I would love Chris Pratt play Clayface that's the
guy he is like a real life clay face he's just
always morphing and changing and coming up with
characters that you would never recognize him in
yes yes Chris Pratt over there I want to make sure
we get to our titles um but yeah I imagine
there'd be multiple villains in the Batman
part two you know probably penguin returning
Joker somewhere in there this is April 1st I
forgot this was April 1st which is April Fool's
Day so I I'm not gonna lie I had a panic attack
once I saw there was a bunch of news that came
out on Twitter today only to be like yeah wait
a minute this is bull [__] and I forget that
like mainstream Outlets like Hollywood Reporter
participate yeah yeah that was like a panic
on the rider like just checking checking stuff
everything I've been prepared for is now is now
just like completely out the window do I have to
adjust for all this stuff oh boy yeah hey Yeti
x what about patrons what's going on buddy what
about super sexy rejects the sex thank you guys
I know we got some more Super chess we'll get
to them in just a little bit I want to make sure
that we're getting to I like I like your picks for
Clayface in the chat who would you have playface
Kevin James is a fantastic pick Jim Holland cast
him twice actually Jim Carrey wouldn't be
a bad pick Jim Carrey would be a great pick
for he's already Clayface I think Matt Reeves
though if he does go with him he he has a he
does an excellent job at going against what you
would normally who you normally expect to play
um any of these characters 90 of the time except
for Zoe Kravitz and and uh and uh and what you may
call it um what's his name my God Jeffrey Wright
Jeffrey commissioner that's right Gordon thank
you to everyone who left a like there's a lot uh
Sergeant let's talk about this Spider-Man news
because that's the that's one of our headlines for
today oh yeah it's a Spider-Man four plot details
going off memory no notes going on John you're
gonna I'm gonna need some uh I got you I need some
assist here I got you I'm here so the Spiderman
for plot details are uh or the main there's been
some reliable sources like sources that have been
proven that hey they've been right kind of a lot
of the time and nothing too spoiler heavy here
um but you know what uh setups yeah some setups
and this is all rumors none of this is confirmed I
could see it being plausible though and you might
have already heard and I did want to touch on this
so what's it all starts with Kingpin funny enough
yes all roads lead to Kingpin so Kingpin as we
know is going to be returning in the Echo series
after dying and being resurrected by the Lazarus
Pit he his returning in the Echo series and of
course he's going to be in Daredevil born again
and supposedly he will be one of the main bad guys
for Spider-Man 4. so it's supposed to be following
a certain kind of comic run where Kingpin once
elected for mayor what he fights for is to have
Vigilantes like the street Vigilantes Daredevil
I mean Punisher you know uh the rest of the
Defenders everyone who's had a television
show basically yeah and then Spider-Man who after
the events of no way home would just be more of a
street-level hero again a protector a neighborhood
friendly Spider-Man to Outlaw vigilantes in New
York which is actually a a concept that I'm
surprised it hasn't been brought up in the MCU
yet we have a very street level MCU to speak of
thus far at least on the big screen I don't feel
like in in the TV shows more so what I mean by
that is the conversation of isn't this a crime
being a vigilante isn't this a crime sure what
they're doing of course Kingpin isn't doing this
to protect the people of New York City he has his
own best interests at heart uh it's something that
is more corrupt so the theory goes that with
the outlawing of Vigilantes he would of course
like if you've played the the first Spider-Man PS4
game that's kind of a good idea good way to gauge
a sort of where I'm imagining they can go with
it's just not with that many villains in there
however it probably hires a villain or two maybe
scorpion so that way he can be the one uh to go
after and take down Spider-Man I imagine Jay
Jonah Jameson would be folded back into the mix
and be even more prevalent who is going yes this
is illegal this is cry this is Criminal what these
heroes are doing they're not government sanctioned
that's why we have sokovia chords in place I think
as we're you know as much as there's been focus
on what does the Multiverse mean for the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and as much hype as there's
been for like Avengers King Dynasty and Secret
Wars I'm weirdly more interested in this because
this feels more intimate this feels darker because
it's posing a like I think that's why the
conversation surrounding Captain America
Civil War was so fascinating and I feel like with
Spider-Man and these other Heroes like Daredevil
especially Daredevil who has like a law background
it's I think it'd just be way more intriguing to
deal with is this actually like criminal activity
and what are they fighting for they're also being
shunned by half of the public like you can get
a little political as much as people say like
that shouldn't be in our movies it's in the
comics you can get a little political about
it and make something that's truly pulsating
and on the run and I think even something like
Captain America New World Order would be dealing
with that set up on a bigger scale too kind
of this reoccurring theme and conversation
going throughout Marvel phase five and six
and then you got like a Multiverse thing going
on at the same time and I think having that for
the street level is more intriguing in my opinion
but what do you guys think John what do you think
of Kingpin yeah being this villain yeah no I
think I mean a that's very exciting because I
you know having Vincent D'Onofrio back has been
an interest an odd Prospect because everyone's
obviously excited about his portrayal everybody
loves his take on the character he loves playing
the character but you know we're still I think
waiting for that satisfying return and we're
also waiting on the big screen live action to see
Spider-Man take on Kingpin who has either been a
prolific Spider-Man villain over the course of
time and I think right now is a point where I
I think the MCU could maybe benefit from a little
contrast because we are going so big in Cosmic and
multiversal and I'm here for that stuff I really
like the Fantastical and the strange however I
think it is uh beneficial to them to have a
contrast with the more street level stuff and
to have those kinds of conversations too it's
like they had some interesting stuff going on
especially with ever everything that transpired
leading into Civil War and the debate about you
know Heroes that led to sokovic Accords and all
that stuff um I think you know you can easily
imagine a world in which Jay Jonah Jameson is
like helping campaign for Kingpin and you know and
using all those resources to throw at Spider-Man
along with you know the other physical Stakes that
he'll have to face and so yeah that seems like
something that would be I think they said there's
like a contract issue where like Spider-Man has to
appear Spiderman Spiderman has to bring you know
an MCU buddy another prolific character along you
know it can't just be only solely Spider-Man at
the center of the movie for some reason um but
I like the idea of that being Kingpin because
that does suggest a more physical challenge and
something that is going to be you know uh even
though Kingpin is a fantastic character you know
he's just a man with his fists and his Force so
I think it'll be really fun and interesting to
see Spider-Man take that on and you know he's
such a colorful character in Vincent d'onofrio's
hands that I just can't wait to see them quit
back and forth together you know and and you know
really find that sort of adversarial uh friction I
would love that I love where your head's at Joe
plus the opportunity to get a daredevil team up
is just too good to pass up and if Kingpin is uh
in Spider-Man's past and you know Daredevil is
going to come into the picture and that's like
the coolest idea like that's something that I
think could unequivocally get people hyped no
matter what reservations you have about phase four
and five and six well I was hearing um I don't
know this came out I saw this on comic book cast
um I'm just making a little chapter note
Spider-Man bought by Disney so apparently I don't
know how how much how true this is um because I'm
seeing seeing some people in the chat bringing
some things up about Spider-Man buying Disney
but the chat was moving a little bit quick here
um oh thank you unnamed film channel for attending
our WonderCon panel uh or that that is that
WonderCon panel was pretty awesome worked off two
hours of sleep that day and so it was a bit of a
blur to me but it was awesome uh but yeah so a big
one of the one of the things going around right
now is that Disney officially bought Spider-Man
for 4.1 billion dollars and it's in five years
where they would have all the rights so Amy Pascal
right now is helping to oversee the the remaining
phase the remaining parts of the Spider-Man was
like Madame Webb and whatever else they're doing
Spiderman buying Disneyland is that what I
said originally Spider-Man Spider-Man that
would be a very interesting takeover so yeah
friendly neighborhood media conglomerate I only
saw this on comic book casts who often just
reports on the news this was not released on
April 1st it was March 31st so unless they were
really trying to get ahead of the game time zone
are they in it's 19 hours okay I am finding
it from Hardware Zone forums here yeah from
14 hours ago which would be that's that's late
last night I I don't know if it's true or not
um I I feel like that would be cool though
certainly I mean I think that would give
everybody this is a doctor strange Cape by the
way yes it is not a spectacular Cape as much
as everyone says that it's not a promotion for
the hit film coming up was it an April Fool's
joke it feels like it because I saw it posted
like March 31st were they in Europe I don't
know if they are no I'm curious I mean like
if it is true I think people would be very
excited if it's not true good joke I think this
stream it would be way more fun if we had more
if we had more fake news it's actually true yeah
we can leave little polls do you think this story
is true yes or no because today's our today's our
April 1st yes it is yeah it's we're 11 and a half
hours into April first you know and I as I don't
know when this com this combo cast thing came out
it I saw it yesterday and it said 19 hours ago
so I'm like I can't have it April 1st yes but
that would be cool if that was the case anyway uh
I know we we've got in a few super chats I want to
make sure I just feel like the big Outlets would
would all be reporting that what are your guys's
thoughts yes on Velma I think we should react to
that react to the film Lady Gaga's out you guys
know how to trigger my anxiety yes this stream
is over let me just try to let me just make sure
first because I only pull this up now if we have
successfully fallen behind clay face Poison Ivy
and scarecrow will be a part of the Batman 2 is
that true Vengeance that would be very a very cool
Trio I mean I'm always rooting for a scarecrow
appearance and uh you know poison ivy I feel
like Matt Reeves's take would be fascinating okay
yeah so John we we oh no we have not fallen behind
here we go we're doing good all right okay we got
a new piece of news in this next one so here we go
um John where's that's spoil their talk graphic
here all right it's up at the top title overlay
so we we're implementing this there's
basically something that Ben Affleck spoiled
regarding the flash a scene that supposedly is
actually cut out of the movie now so I don't think
it's that big of a spoiler sure um because if
everything is happening with the DC Universe and
on top of that too everyone's saying that it's cut
out of the movie this is just how they mark it now
but I wanted to talk about this scene because
it when reading the quotes especially from Ben
Affleck it was the first time you know what
because this whole time my my mindset has been
Ben Affleck has just wanted to move on and just
have everyone shut the [__] up about that like
let him be right let me and then he the way he
was talking about specifically when going over
to this scene and the way he was being like Oh I
know I quit but man I finally figured it out and
stuff like oh it seems like he was actually kind
of you know there was a partner was a little bit
there's a little hints of like maybe I want to
go yeah circumstances I would love to explore
more now that I finally know how to play the guy
uh going off memory of the scene I'm gonna put up
this graphic this is when we're gonna be done once
this graphic goes away and please help us out in
the chat if someone comes in and goes hey what
are they talking about it says talking spoilers
here what's the spoiler talking about please let
them know what it is um so I'm just gonna put that
right there I'm able to move this on screen John
yeah you can move it wherever you like and you can
change the size that's right please there you go
King spoilers yeah I'm gonna put this right here
for now yeah okay cool groovy so what happened
in case you guys haven't heard it's really not
that big of a deal but there's a scene that
happens in The Flash movie Apparently that is
now cut out of the film where did you read about
this I did okay I know the report all right so
Ben Affleck's Batman at one point is rescued by
Wonder Woman and she used and part of rescuing
him is using the lasso of Truth so you know when
the last truth is wrapped around you what comes
out the truth about how you really feel under
yeah he poops he just shits everywhere and Ben
Affleck was like I now know how to play about that
he's always on the face always happens [Laughter]
if I don't [__] I will Channel my
rage I know how to play Batman now
forget about the pain in my intestine yeah anyway
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah no he he tells he spills
some sort of intimate truths about himself in
this moment to Wonder Woman and through that I
guess it helped Ben Affleck to sort of Greater
understand the depth of Bruce Wayne and how to
play him yeah which would have been a fascinating
scene to see because especially with Ben Affleck's
Batman who is the furthest thing from open and
vulnerable like you already kind of associate
that with Batman as a as a gentleman who has a
hard time opening up what we've seen like with
Christian Bales and and uh Val kilmers at least
you know get a little bit of a soft they would
have moments where they get soft and vulnerable
and with Ben Affleck's you don't get that and I
I think it would have been an interesting thing
to actually have that scene unfold so yeah he
does spoil that oh you would have gotten this
really heartfelts and that Wonder Woman makes
it makes a solid appearance in that film and
it seems like they they cut that whole thing
out and I would be curious to know to have
that scene at least revealed one day because
I imagine that was one of his more emotional
scenes that he's ever had to have filmed you
know it feels like one of those things that could
easily be like a heart swell of like relief like
oh cool oh surprise Wonder Woman's here but also
yeah like a surprisingly poignant moment between
two characters that do know each other and have
history you know on screen for a lot of the dce
would have helped narratively Drive the plot
forward of whatever's going on with helping to
transition the Batman out sure like that kind of
probably could have aided in being a goodbye scene
for him yeah literally a moment of vulnerability
before we yeah say goodbye you know peek into his
soul would be a really nice sort of way to cap
that off however you know not to say that there
was not another scene they do have and plan to
keep in the movie that could serve that purpose
as well uh I don't know I like I yeah I'm I'm
sad to hear if it's not in the movie because
it seems like a cool idea and you know you could
easily then add it to the classic list of scenes
where people are interacting with the lasso like
Aquaman and Justice League and now this so uh you
know we're being robbed we're being robbed right
robbed but yeah I don't know I I would love to
see the scene in some form I don't know how
do you guys feel about the scene getting cut
out does it bother you are you pissed this video
is sponsored by athletic greens athletic greens
as we talk about [__] several times on this
stream today keep yourself regular yourself
shooting some more with athletic greens don't
[__] out junk food [__] has some good vitamins
and minerals all right move past that thing but
thanks for asking cool cash G hey DC loves Henry
you goddamn right they do Henry Cavill for Wonder
Woman John what's going on here what's with this
button I don't know gotta get rid of this button
I don't know uh all right that's fine all right
Alvin Lane thank you so much for the Super Chat
my friend from patreon Ellen Ling what's up uh
we just gave you a big old group shout
out hey Greg and John hi I know we were
getting a secret Invasion trailer but we're
also getting spider-verse and Blue Beetle I
don't know exciting look out yeah the scoopers
been scooping and it looks like it's happening
uh secret Invasion trailer manana spider-verse
I think it's crazy they were getting all three
it's just like and is there something going on if
it feels like there should be a consistency event
like E3 just got canceled so it can't be that
because there's also supposed to be the trailer
um that I'm hearing rumors about for the Robert
Rodriguez directed Ben Affleck movie and we're
Wonder Woman Wonder Woman we just spoiled it
without the spoiler reporting on her and then we
also are getting rumors that and it looks likely
as well that the new Hunger Games trailers coming
out this week oh good everyone's excited for
the new Hunger Games somehow I gotta squeeze in
a Creed Three movie reaction as well it's gonna
be good pull an all-nighter for the Mandalorian
so it suddenly turned into a very daunting week
very busy week which is a good problem to have
it's just I don't understand sometimes with these
trailer releases I don't get it where they you'll
you'll get nothing for so long especially now and
then then there'll be a weekend where they're like
hey fire everything yeah every Studio goes just
release it off yeah yeah that was the time that's
what they want maybe that's it let's have overlap
with each other let's do Mass scarcity and then
just a whole batch release all at once yeah it's
it's strange because two they don't release these
things as far out in advance as it seems like they
used to it seems like nowadays like three months
out is kind of The Sweet Spot and we are heading
right into summertime like spring just started
you know 10-ish days ago or you know 11 days ago
and uh yeah it's like we're heading toward the
beginning of what will be summer season so it
makes sense to start getting trailers but also
it is like what is it about this weekend what is
it about April Fool's weekend that is so special
um but yeah very excited to see what all
of them look like especially a new Robert
Rodriguez joint I know and I've heard good
things it played at uh what's that called s m
sxsida says sex in the chat because yeah that
that one always sounds like sex to me yeah
um yeah and apparently they they screen an early
cutter Rodriguez's movie there but it's still got
amazing feedback and I was so happy to hear that
for Robert Rodriguez I know I'm always rooting
Jim Carrey's old Clayface so many people
could play clayfic get Brian Cox in my
face I think he would be a good clay face in
Matt Reeves Universe Shadow realm BG thank
you so much for the Super Chat here hey
hey greetings from Bulgaria do you think
secret Invasion going to deliver bigger
than we think keep doing the good content
I think the new conversation we need to have
surrounding the Marvel Cinematic Universe is
I'll be patient and wait yes instead of this is
going to be a game changer I feel like it'll be
a good thing uh I'm planning on reading see I
could I could I looked at how long the Run was
for seeking Invasion I feel like I can read
it uh pretty fast I'm planning on reading it
closer to one secret Invasion debuts even though
I feel like it's probably gonna be nothing like
I think in the comic um because I'm aware of
what happens in the comic but I think that with
secret Invasion it is essentially picking up from
events from Captain Marvel more than anything else
um that'll be a lot more honed in and
focused on characters like Talos and
Nick Fury and what they're dealing with and
you kind of get I don't mean Captain America
rephrase not Civil War doesn't make a cold war
Vibe about it yeah yeah yeah yeah you get this
sort of feels like the Civil War you know it's
like the American like Ulysses S Grant yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah emancipating all of the Scrolls
yeah uh no yeah I think this could be a certain
opportunity at least to return to to return to
a tone not exactly like the Winter Soldier but
something that has that political thriller Vibe
and yes something that Harkens more toward Cold
War paranoia type movies especially like that's
a really good uh uh Touchstone yeah because it's
like who is hiding Among Us who is you know the
concealed enemy you know dressed as our friend
and whatever else and what sort of interesting
conversations can you have based on that like
I think it is a good opportunity for them to do
something rich uh and I hope that they take it uh
yeah I'm sort of same thing I I'm I'm waiting to
see how everything pans out and I'm trying not to
let my excitement Carry Me Away ahead of
myself for these different things because
the shows have shown uh over I think average
at least there are certain shows that really
kind of nail it across the board but a lot of
them have these really great elements and then
have these particular shortcomings that aren't
too hard to spot and so I'm hoping that they're
just taking notes on all this I think it's
good that they are taking their time granted
this has been you know uh it's part of the wave
of like we're gonna do tons and tons of content
um but I I hope that this can kind of set a new
sort of stage for what's to come tonally well it
sounds like it could also be surprisingly personal
I think so too yeah yeah and I mean I really liked
the Scrolls and their sort of storyline in Captain
Marvel and the relationship with uh Talos and Nick
Fury so like I'm excited to see that stuff
extrapolated on you know and and two just the
fun of you know peep shapeshifters and copycats
we must move on I'm secretly doing this I can I
what is that what are you doing where's the show
where's the words I was just responding to now I
don't know what I was talking about Dakota Jones
we got some from Dakota Jones our good friend one
virus effects over here let's interrupt this this
is not confirmed tasm three I will not fall you
gotta do better everyone Ah that's a that's an
April Fool right I want to see who in the chat
can contribute and April Fool's headline to me
and actually yeah yeah like what is convincing
but don't worry that's true that would be yeah I
would have stopped this stream right now John you
were reading Dakota Jones yeah no there's no news
report Dakota Jones Will Bill Skarsgard playing
Pennywise uh with Bill Skarsgard now the crow and
Nosferatu what other iconic role Cosmic or horror
could you you see him tackle next I don't want
him to play a villain next I want him to play
like actually make him Jason Todd I want him to do
that I feel like he'd be a fantastic Clayface sure
great idea actually yeah yeah yeah yeah because
no matter which version the Mike Flanagan more
artistic fan of the Opera Vibe Gothic horror
version the the Batman Matt Reeves version or
even the more fun side of the DCU of James Gunn
I think well that's the thing yeah as you could
uh Clayface is a fun opportunity because there
are so many takes and so many Origins and and
many characters who have worn that mantle and you
could really crash a lot of those things together
yeah even like so many of them don't necessarily
preclude the others so you could make them all
part of this weird sort of amorphous history and
yeah Bill Skarsgard honestly that's a good call
man it would be I think him as Clayface would be
good honestly well then cast them uh people have
been asking about a Dun Dungeons and Dragons in
the chat and uh I personally am waiting for it to
come to VOD it's up to John if he wants to wait
or not absolutely wait it sounds like a blast
and I would I'm not asking you to wait I'm saying
you have the choice it would be a joy to react to
you so unless you're giving me a thinly veiled
hint that you don't I don't want you near me
I'm not picking up I'm more than happy to enjoy it
with you here in the lovely and Posh real reject
Studio my uncle thank you for this thingy I don't
know the Creed was my one for the year yeah I was
like I'll see this no I always have to I will
never ask anyone else to wait unless it's like
please John Wayne yes cocaine bear was like hey
did you see this in theaters now all right let's
react to it yeah um okay I'll be there for Evil
Dead don't worry um Colby Stephens uh Transformers
official trailer will drop this week geez Jesus
Christo the part that stresses me about this
even though I know people don't require us to be
experts is I really do my best to to research a
bunch beforehand and and it bums me out because
my brain can only handle so much because I don't
just have a memory game I got it because it's like
it's always diverted between like oh my personal
the other things I'm working on and then editing
and whatever and my my Noggin can like to give
you an example I watched all of Attack on Titan
and then part three comes out I'm like ah [__]
I need a I need a refresher and then I decided
I'm just going to read the Manga because it's
pretty accurate to the show and I'm reading it and
I'm almost done with where I need to catch up to
and I'm like I forgot so much of what happened I
didn't remember the most important history impact
stories leading in so my brain just misses stuff
all the like because and and it sucks because I
do I do commit a lot of time in a research side or
to either watch especially I'll read a lot of the
actual Source material or I'll take the time to
like watch the Star Wars animated shows and then
I'll still miss stuff and it bums me up that's
bum me up I want to see a map so Transformers of
like oh my God I don't remember so much about it
the Beast Wars now yeah I don't know anyone who's
a Transformers expert you could you could hire
John Bailey I could hire John Bailey actually
it's not bad call yeah he's the Transformer
Joshua J Gonzalez thank you for joining in and
and participating and contributing I just noticed
that you guys aren't sitting on your actual chairs
we are actually however they've been rearranged
placed in different spots true yeah I'm usually
in the spider chair when I'm with the G train
but uh we're on the different sides today uh I
want to talk about Michael Mando super quick for
just one minute yes um because Michael Mando if
you guys don't know he was in Better Call Saul as
nacho but also he was scorpion in the Spider-Man
Homecoming movie and I like that really didn't do
much for me for him and homecoming I was like huh
sucks with that actor to not be coming back but
after seeing him as nacho and Better Call Saul
bit would be a complete oh man uh you are
missing out on a great opportunity because
he is phenomenal in that series phenomenal and
I would hope that if any of these rumors for the
next Spider-Man movie are true I mean you got to
bring scorpion into the equation like we haven't
gotten scorpion yet you got to bring scorpion into
the equation and if you don't bring Michael Mando
back you are doing yourself a disservice Sony
and Marvel well yeah I mean he and uh Adrian
tombs are in prison together so yeah or they were
until Adrian tombs got sprung so true gotta come
back in some way shape or form uh let's see here
Cruz Rivera thank you for the moment of silence
and uh yeah and uh you know Velma is definitely
coming reactions in the series oh yeah yeah we're
gonna prioritize Velma I want to watch a show
to hate it all all week rage watch we won't we
won't win with Velma hello to Venezuela it's
nice to have you in the chat uh what do you
think of Tyler's returning Captain America four
I'm sure it'll be a great Cameo yeah I do it I
love everybody I feel like it's going to be as
special as people think it's more like yeah it's
just still remember she still counts yeah I know
just still count this movie is still technically
Canon even though the universal stuff is hinky
yeah no I mean I've seen all those reports of
people going like well they can't make a Hulk
movie called The Hulk so they're just gonna
make Captain America The Hulk yeah and I'm
like I don't think that's gonna happen even
if there are red hulks and other characters
relevant to the Hulk even if the Hulk himself
is a big character I think it would be a pretty
disrespectful to Anthony mackie's first feature
is Captain America to make it a Hulk movie
instead you know I need a I need a I need
a oh my god oh we did it always afraid you've
got a loser so money baby you're better than me
at this I mean I I did see Aaron but briefly
saw it in this quick scheme but I would love
for Daredevil to appear in the next Spider-Man
movie I think if there's an MCU character that
makes the most sense to appear alongside of uh
Spider-Man if that's part of the Sony contract
which I think it is I think Daredevil makes the
most sense and who the hell wouldn't want to see
that yeah that would be awesome and especially
if he doesn't know it's Matt Murdock after Matt
Murdock was his lawyer who defended him in no
way home all right doesn't know it's him yeah
no I mean I I because because Tom Holland wouldn't
know that Daredevil and Matt Murdoch are the same
yeah okay yeah yeah okay yeah yeah and then
and then Matt Murdoch just would have no idea
of course Mr blind man how can you see so good
a resident nerd man thank you so much did you
guys hear gun officially cast Nick Cage as
Superman and Batman what a win ah you think
I fall for such a thing John do your do your
Nicholas Cage impression do you bleed you will
I do a Superman line I'm a big fan of
Justin you went with the just we didn't
always man that's the canonical version all
right so the account is going to continue
that's the one that the Warner Brothers
wants to hang their hat on so I'm a I'm
a show for the WB did she yes dude yeah
I think the April Fool's thing is funny
um some people really hate it it just it just
freaked me out of my I think it depends I can I
can fall for some [__] though sure I yeah I fell
for one this morning Thanos dizzy Plus show coming
I think we should do just like a Thanos home
renovation show where it's just him like at his
Hut making making fixes mayank uh thank you so
much for the stupid chat uh John why don't you
read it my friend hey hi Greg and John hello from
India hello to India huge fan here my question is
what's the future of one of them majors in the MCU
given the recent events uh that's the question and
there isn't yet an answer because we just don't
know unfortunately and and the latest batch of uh
recasting with Bill skars wait yeah just throw up
anyways that have him play every villain from here
on yeah uh yeah I mean it is certainly right now
it seems like they're just taking everything under
consideration and if it turns out that uh he can't
that it is guilty Beyond A Reasonable Doubt then
they're gonna recast and if not then they won't
yeah um I think that John when I said this this
is two minutes Oh I thought that was like two
seconds finger things okay okay and uh timings
yeah and I'm just going to say it out loud so
everyone know I don't want to lie to you guys how
the sausage is made this means this means once one
minute you're making a great point please continue
I don't know if anybody actually saw it the the
the I mean yeah for Jonathan Majors I think wait
till it plays out and see what happens because I
I don't it's such a divide right now I think if
you go on Twitter it will be very easy to believe
that everyone feels like the text messages just
prove that Jonathan Majors is abusive and if you
saw our video the yesterday you know like even for
us we're like I can understand how one side would
believe this proves was innocent and the other
side would completely believe this proves he's an
abusive [__] yeah right like it can either one
can be proven they can't hear the tone of voice in
this text so and I'm telling you it was definitely
alarming for us as well but you know no we're not
we're right now with the like we'll if they have
a video I'd rather just wait for that yeah I think
that Johnny Depp trial really just put everything
in a different role before we believe anything
let's just wait to hear yeah yeah yeah yeah
before we conclude we should really wait it out
a little bit well yeah because at least that that
trial taught us how ugly and messy and gray all
this stuff can't be so yeah it's like you really
don't the court of public opinion doesn't know any
better than the people with the actual evidence
even if they are trying to spin out evidence so
I I think right now the way it's going about it
to try to like instantly do damage control is not
smart PR standpoint not smart it's not creating
the alleviation I believe there are conversations
happening uh I I wouldn't be surprised that I
think they should be having conversations about
what are we doing daily and and honestly you know
with with it being Multiverse and variants and
all that [__] like I think you can recast uh
worst case as great as he is as king um I I
totally think you can throw Michael I think
you can recast to me it's not the flash situation
where they already spent all this money and they
filmed it and everything and yeah you can't just
reshoot that [__] you know oh yeah and worst
case if somebody did come in with a new face that
would at least lead to a big old surprise yeah in
in real time watching the movie I think just get
the whitest skinniest guy you can find uh Ginger
geeked happy birthday to you my friend hey happy
birthday to you Nicholas Pages Bruce Wayne face
that's coming or James Corden is Clayface
also a perfect casting Choice yes definitely
uh second James Corden good I like the
Leaky face Vengeance the main thing that
Spider-Man has going for it and Sony is the
is the uh the spider-verse films man yeah
um oh apparently there's a basketball game and
that's why all these trailers are dropping I
don't know [__] that yeah we gotta tune into
the basketball game we gotta find some way to
get nerds to tune into this sporting event well
you know I used to think about that like is that
what they're trying to do get us to tune in but
I think it's mainly to appeal to all the people
who don't follow this stuff regularly yeah
we're gonna slip this nerd [__] into your
basket because once in a while I do catch
something that's randomly on someone else's
television if I'm over the place and I'm like
oh let's go uh so I should watch more basketball
say on it works both ways thank you for the
Super Chat my friend uh thank you for everyone
who's here uh please leave a like if you're if
you're if you haven't done so already because
um yeah that helps with the playback I think
it almost big contributoring Super Chat uh
Sean what's up Greg and John bit of fans is 500k
right around there I decided I'm gonna be a fan of
clout that I can commit to fandom I wish I could
have saw you guys at WonderCon uh it's okay next
time you're here giving a very generous Super
Chat that means way more yeah what's your top
five worst TV shows you've ever seen sending them
all the way from Dallas funny enough I met a guy
at the gym today Josh who's from Houston um anyway
the top five worst TV shows I've ever seen I don't
know what the work I've never stuck it out with a
worse TV show never just been like this is garbage
I have to finish this we've even done that on
patreon like there's been shows that were just
like this is even though people are watching
at our patreon I'm like was not driving for
us like we're just not enjoying it yeah remember
criteria for shows that we cover the main three
criteria is are we genuinely interested in it
um will are and will our audience be interested
in it and how much traction will it bring it
you know yeah um so that's like the the three
the three areas you want to try to hit for for us
we but we always do start with are we interested
um but I could tell you some of
the most disappointing endings
for me that I've experienced with
TV because there's I would say
both endings of Dexter the rebooted ending and the
actual and the first ending and the actual ending
um Game of Thrones is a sad experience
overall and uh those reaction that was a
really sad experience and that that that makes
me go like too I want to commit to a re-watch
um I know yeah Hill is gonna crash I didn't
hate Iron Fist to disagree that everyone else
hated it but I think when you put it in the
influx of so many great hits uh like you know
Luke Cage Daredevil and Jessica Jones that's
a real bummer um and God you know I I think
I can't really think of uh yeah like I said I I'm
willing to quit a show if it ain't working for me
especially yeah in the past several years it's
it's to that point we're just like yeah if I'm
not invested in this there's not all the time
in the world so I'll go look at something else
uh yeah I mean God I wish I had a better answer
to this question it's true like uh the ending
of Game of Thrones certainly comes to mind the
ending of like the endings of things like uh you
know how How I Met Your Mother or a Walking Dead
certainly was the first show that I actually that
was the first show where I like had the moment
with myself where I was like you know what
I'm gonna stop that I used to love this and
now I I can just feel myself going through
the motions apparently it got like amazing
that's what I've after like several foreign
supernatural has like a banger 11 season and
I think people were saying it's like 10 or
11 for Walking Dead where they're like no they
got a New Soul Runner it's freaking great now
yeah and and part of me is always like maybe
I'll just jump back in on on I'll just skip
some of those seasons and just go to this and
uh I don't know if it would be a goddamn Rick
movie it's apparently still on the table and they
have like new Walking Dead spin-offs coming to HBO
so maybe okay it's a secret well I mean that's our
answer for that there's not really anything if I
come up with more disappointing shows I'll let
you know I mean Jessica Jones certainly petered
out and got pretty tedious and that was a bummer
because the season's in the first one was so good
yeah yeah yeah I'm trying to think if there was
any like particularly wretched Pilots or anything
like that at least I think book of Boba Fett in
retrospect is is a weird disappointing experience
when you had Decades of figures yeah and made
all the more disappointing by the fact that
there is good work in it and it's so misshapen
that it yeah it doesn't really uh honor that
um but Luis Morales uh I I can answer this one um
are you guys going to watch Superman and Lois I'm
assuming for season three I appreciate the inquiry
here Luis and of course a Super Chat asking about
it uh for Superman and Lois season three well it's
funny enough we were we were just bringing up what
we were saying our criteria is recovering shows
because you know I don't know what the there's
been some changes happening here but behind
the scenes like we've uploaded significantly
less and after evaluation of how not only how
much stuff we put out last year but also how
um how like mentally and emotionally uh can be
affecting like when the camera's not rolling
especially but then also how it can bleed into
camera you know I feel like a big part of what
happened with Brooklyn Nine-Nine and why we ended
up losing viewership I've noticed like for there's
a solid period where people were like Greg looks
bored I'm like no the truth is I'm just really
[__] tired and you know I can still enjoy
something really tired but I'm not going to
be as expressive because I'm tired I'm like that
in real life when I'm more tired I'm probably not
going to be as expressive in conversation like
it's just the way it goes and for Superman and
Lois as much as we really enjoyed that show it
just it's plain and simple for like the 16 with
the 10 to 16 weeks or whatever it's like 16 week
commitment or something like that yeah it simply
just did not generate both seasons but especially
the second season did not generate the viewership
you know like we're interested in it generates the
viewership and then it's like okay I can commit
like the extra hours to editing and but it won't
really pay off in the end because it'll be like so
many more extra hours and the other part sometimes
that we do is like okay but you know it's like
is it getting are the watch alongside our patreon
getting that much are we getting a good conversion
there because in order to balance everything that
that happens here because to be totally honest
with you guys like there's been there's plenty
of days and there's a period I worked every day
up until the day before my wedding you know and
there's a lot of times where I'll be working like
because a lot of the making the editing and
thumbnails even if we get people who uh like
we have prepper who helps us edit we're still very
much involved on the re-edits for those things and
a lot of times that can be so much extra time
and the most important thing that it tends to
come down to for this channel is oh yeah but
when we're filming we have to be like alive you
know yeah and that can that can greatly affect
the experience of Superman Lois on top of that
too with not many people were just watching at
our patreon we'd have like a consistently eight
to nine people at our patreon watching it and as
much as we enjoyed the show the interest is just
not as like for the people who were watching the
same consecutive people bottom line is like I was
definitely invested in getting editors to help out
with that one and didn't even break even on that
investment and so I kind of have to pay attention
to that personally because I gotta make sure
all the guests who we bring on here the regulars
that I get to pay them I got to make sure John
gets paid I gotta make sure the editors get
they're gonna make sure everyone's getting
paid and then also you know I if you were look
at my bank account right now I there's like a
real rejects bank account because I had to set it
up as a business and I don't really pay myself I
um I pay myself for what I need to for my living
expenses basically like I pay myself just enough
to but I also want to make sure everyone else is
getting paid so I know it's kind of a convoluted
answer but there's a lot that factors in into
do we commit to this for 16 weeks and what was
the experience like and did it and then okay
ultimately with doing the analytics on this
yeah like both seasons it just it actually
ended up as much as I enjoyed the show it was
did not even break even on the investment for
it which is which I just got to face reality on
something like that and eventually you sometimes
just get to a position but I'm just going to be
honest with you guys like this is a conversation
a lot of YouTubers have and I normally don't feel
comfortable discussing this because it sounds
I understand that there can be one version of
this that can sound like Greg just thinking about
views and money I'm like well not yes there is a
factor to that but yeah but I am also thinking
of well the work versus reward on this will not
really be a pay like I'll pull an all-nighter for
Mandalorian because I know it's going to do well
yeah it's about that investment but Superman
and Lois will like that'll if I'm editing it
you know those will take me like three to four
hours to edit than making the thumbnails will
take like another hour and then then at the end
of it all I'm like okay well that's made like
forty five dollars yeah yeah it just yeah in
in the grand scheme of things it's kind of
like dropping a rock in your boat a little bit
and you always hope that you know it'll it'll
and then when you put all that in perform well
but when you put all that investment and time
and energy into it and then you don't get it it
actually can affect the viewing experience well
then that's the weird part and I hate when that
happens with that when that affects the enjoyment
because I will enjoy it more just watching on
my own especially with the show as good as that
because also too it's like it's a really great
show it's really fun to watch and then it's a
bummer when more people don't join in with us to
have the experience because then it's like oh you
know like what are we doing wrong because we're
not we're not helping people some people really
like I remember like we didn't cover Doom
Patrol and people like well Doom Patrol is
failing then you're not helping by not covering
it and I'm like well to be honest with you we
we're not part of the promo people who watch our
[__] after they're already watching it yeah
it's not people going wow I watched all these
reactions now I'll go check this show out now
that I know all that's gonna happen yeah yeah yeah
um because yeah one one metric that we have for it
is okay is it doing well on our patreon at least
and then we'll keep it going but I was like oh
only like eight to nine people are watching this
on our patreon yeah this is like that's not good
numbers yeah um so yeah after a while you do got
to make that choice to just scrap it but you know
at the same time like I said there have been shows
that at our patreon that we were covering that we
liked that that we were not liking but people were
watching but because we weren't liking it we were
like we gotta can it because we're not liking
it um yeah it's not translating into it it's
criteria I wanted to give a detailed answer on
that because I know there's been like uh they're
getting that comment a lot so I'm just going
to clip that portion out and then release it
somewhere let me make a time around the 50 minute
Mark in this stream alrighty guys well thank you
um but thank you guys for listening hearing me
out on that crooked um thank you so much for the
Super Chat have we given up on Andrew Garfield
having another solo Spider-Man movie did morbius
kill that feel I could kill that possibility John
I spent a long time explaining Superman Lois thing
why don't you answer that question for Cricket
thank you for the Super Chat sure uh I certainly
don't think morbius helped that although I guess
I would say for my own view of the situation that
a third Andrew Garfield Spider-Man solo outing
has always felt like another one of those uh
unprecedented events I know everyone was
really riding high off Spider-Man no way
home and everything they were able to achieve
with that and honoring his character there and
I I certainly think that the possibility Still
Remains that he could on the suit again but like
any any announcement of an Andrew Garfield Amazing
Spider-Man 3 to me would be like a pretty solid
surprise like they're building this thing with Tom
Holland still and I do think that while there is
that level of enthusiasm for Andrew Garfield and
Toby McGuire they've talked to him as well about
coming back certainly the whole Spider-Man Amazing
Spider-Man 3 or or Spider-Man 4 stuff is very much
and I'll believe it when I see it kind of thing I
believe they would make an appearance sooner than
they would actually invest hundreds of millions of
dollars into continuing a franchise that's already
you know been you know kind of had the the the
the Box shut on it it's funny because you know as
James Gunn is trying to get this DC Universe uh in
line because he's like dude you got this timeline
you got this timeline you got this we got a we
gotta find a way to streamline some of this you
know to make one specific timeline and then have
an elsewhere thing going on right it's funny that
with Spider-Man no way home they landed themselves
in a position where they easily could have done
all three Spider-Man movies they could have done
all three uh Spider-Man four with Toby Maguire uh
uh so uh Amazing Spider-Man 3 and continue Tom
Holland's yeah they because no way home was a
massive success and they made it crystal clear
that each individual story lines for them yeah
and I think audiences would tune in for each one
of those movies especially after no way home like
you they had a they have a gold mine on their
hands that they could have really capitalized
and hone in on but it seems like they're making
no real effort or plans to go through with that
which is pretty pretty insane to me because
that they're the the thing that James Gunn is
concerned about with the DC Universe I'm like
well Spider-Man the universe actually wouldn't
have that problem it wouldn't be it wouldn't be
confusing for people yeah because there's no way
home made it clear yeah yeah exactly I mean yeah
I I guess my question then would just be like what
is the restriction from the Marvel side I feel
like that would be the biggest red screw that
Victoria Alonso ruin everything because you want
to promote a weird movie or something sure yeah
Marvel directs these movies Corey Handler from
New Orleans thank you so much for being here Corey
or yeah yeah Louisiana and Sarah Williamson also
right there that's good here that's good to hear
playing um ah you guys recognize me from
patreon of course I didn't think you would haha
yeah you're just numbers to
us at our patreon number 5042.
asking as we're a week out what do
you think will get out of Star Wars
celebration any movies finally more TV
shows I don't know man lucasfilm is in
a weird [__] situation man we'll just get
more canceled projects um yeah I I have no idea
best we're canceling here's everything not
to look forward to that would be hilarious
um that's for today they should do that today
I think we're gonna get more official acolyte
announcements because they're in the process of
getting all these directors and I mean have they
started filming acolyte have they I know they're
talking a lot about it Skeleton Crew is the one
with you yeah and the Daniels are doing one and
so oh that's what's happening am I confused about
that I I don't remember which one Jude Law is
in is he still believe that his Skeleton Crew
and then the Downs are being quartered for that
not acolyte yeah they did they've at least done
I think it's already shot one episode of the of
uh skeletons but is it that I think we'll finally
get and I think Ahsoka trailer will actually drop
online uh I feel like it'll be in conjunction my
prediction is that Mandalorian season three will
have an episode that features Ahsoka since that
are deciding to introduce all the Star Wars Rebels
in there so I think it'll have um Ahsoka and then
um and then after around that time whatever
plot line we get then we can get an Ahsoka
trailer that makes sense yeah yeah that's uh
especially as they're quite teasing all these
uh Rebels characters because like the space
whale I always read the day with them with
the space spells in episode one massive part of
the finale of Star Wars Rebels and then of course
uh Zeb being introduced and after thrawn being
mentioned in season two and uh I don't think she
there's any name of Ezra mentioned uh but you know
Ezra Bridger is supposed to be in at Ahsoka show
I believe so yeah uh I don't know I don't think
they're gonna announce any movies I do holiday
special I really think the time for Kathleen
Kennedy time for Kathleen Kennedy to end uh I
I think the time of Kathleen Kennedy leaving will
probably come a little bit after uh Indiana Jones
I think it's um yeah let the current projects
ride out oh the pasta kill it if you have to
um oh that's interesting to hear about Daredevil
Born Again taking place during and after the blip
I like that actually I've heard that's that
being an explanation as to maybe why foggy and
Karen are back well yeah I mean they also uh
or has there been a newer development I don't
know doesn't matter I hope they'd bring back
that election she was amazing hey Bad Medicine
thanks for being here bud or is it buds thanks
for being here Chris Rock is scarecrow that's
an all right stand up special oh did you watch
it I watched the Marlon Wayans one that's who
you went with you didn't watch the Chris Rock one
did you really choose the Marlon Wayans stand up
over the Chris Rock stand up I mean not in those
direct I wasn't sitting there going which one do
I watch I just happen to have watched the Marlon
Wayans one you didn't even bother to check out
the Chris Rock one I mean I heard the clip of
him talking about Will Smith and all that stuff
this was like the most anticipated stand of
all time and it was okay and that's what I
heard that's why I was like I'll watch the
clip and then eventually if I'm really that
compelled I'll go watch the whole specials okay
and I thought it was a prior one was brilliant
okay whatever the first Netflix one he did I
thought that was brilliant okay uh let's see
here that one instead Bad Medicine is the [__]
subscribe to Bad Medicine if you guys haven't
done so already it will be worth your time and
money absolute vodka Adam Sandler as Magneto I
love it I don't have to bear metal or Ash cows
um Johnny thank you so much for the Super Chat
my friend oh John God specifically oh your top
five directors today and top five of all time
I'm putting a timer on you or else we'll be
here forever yeah I don't know this is gonna
be tricky uh 90 seconds to speak from your
subconscious best director's working right
now I like Panos cosmoto's a lot I like like
uh uh I mean I always enjoy in a great joint um
um on the spot it's so hard come on John uh
I'm trying to think of movies I I've enjoyed
speak from your heart um um uh it's uh you guys
one minute John I I'm not I I would have to look
um yeah you panic Under Pressure don't do it
yeah my mind is clear Don't Panic Under Pressure
John I'm trying not to uh um do you like Quentin
Tarantino I like Quentin Tarantino right yes you
said Edgar Rodriguez I always like a Rodriguez
joint really okay do you like Christopher Nolan
yeah Christopher Nolan's great stay Adventure
is yeah I'm in big respect I already asked I
don't really claim him as a fave uh res is
great uh I don't like have that like uh got
a John Carpenter is is certainly one sure um a
female director but I I don't know who to who
to pull they don't direct movies my producers
dude the male ones yes that's true that's right
Karen kusama I do I do like her stuff a
lot um we'll go there for right now bam
is his name ten directors for John you're
good and he said like he likes you're much
you're much better at off the doming those
kinds of things than me I need to like look
up my I need to look up and there's no
time to think you just go from the heart
um yeah I'll I'll learn your skills
pressure creates diamonds it can
or it makes you shrink up it's one of the two
I mean pressure clears my head out and then I'm
and that's when I re that's the irony I'm like
why couldn't you be here when I was meditating
um Heather couldn't my head be clear then
uh Heather gear thank you for being here
um super sad I wasn't local to make your panel
oh it's okay you could have driven someone drove
10 hours just to it they literally arrived
and then left WonderCon after 10 hours and
I thought that was incredible and he had such a
great girlfriend uh because she drove the whole
way and I know she certainly seemed like she did
that for him I bet she had no idea who we were
and she and I love seeing that Dynamic
for like the two Live Events we've done
recently I love seeing when someone has a
significant other and the significant other
has no clue who we are yes um anyway
she asks do you think the mid and does
she gets you care you care too much to get
Danny Boyle there you go you care too much
there's like a worry that I think that you're
not you're not saying you're not giving the
proper answer and I think you're lean to me yeah
it's like I want to give the answer that I feel
is spiritually right for me but I also want to
give an answer I think is a good answer like a
quality answer because I don't know if I'm just
like naming Rando directors then I don't feel
good I think you have a fear that kicks in
and that fear is what creates this blockage
it could be but if you lead with love oh
it's so much easier to find that answer
okay that's why I mean my come from the heart okay
because you'll find it from there instead of like
am I oh uh uh people were mean to me growing up
what do I do that's what I was thinking about
when I was thinking about these directors I was
like who was there for me when people were mean
Danny Boyle that's who's there for me another
gears uh do you think the mid end credits are
still enjoyable for the MCU DC EU uh they what
was I I think black panther would kind of forever
weirdly has been washed away even for me when I
like talk about what Marvel's been like lately
I'm like oh yeah I forgot I love that movie
and that was one of the more recent ones yeah
um and you know the Henry Cavill one was pretty
awesome they're they're still like corny and
cheesy and sequel setups sure uh but I think
they're still fairly enjoyable uh I don't hate
them like the the DC one is the first Shazam Fury
of the Gods was a little crunchy sure last one a
little cringy sure yeah you know how we felt about
the King Dynasty certainly it is one of those
where they are requisite now so there isn't the
spontaneity so much but they're so fun and excited
because there's still that there's still mystery
boxes because you know that they will likely one
will have some odd to do with the movie and then
one will likely be toward the future but like
you know the without going too specifically even
though probably everyone's seen quantumania like
the post post credits a bit I was very excited
about uh and I thought was like a really cool
little scene so like yeah it happens it's just
now I just a clip I don't think those really count
it's like we had some low-key footage it's
the equivalent of playing a trailer to me it
is you know for sure and and what was the movie
where they showed the doctor strange Multiverse
Madness yeah so like yeah like I don't care
as much for that philosophy yeah I did enjoy
that scene so yeah it's like it's I I think the
sheen is a little bit dispelled now but I think
I think uh I'll give myself 30 seconds here
I think the the point with um just uh to go
off of the point here sure is it's been a while
since it's been a while it's been a while since
we had a post credits like I love the Black
Panther one because we're kind of forever
because it was so emotional it felt like a real
scene that added to the ending of transmission
whereas but the last time there was a big
credit scene didn't just feel like yeah that
makes sense yeah sure that's what's going
to happen yeah like if Henry Cavill wasn't
ruined that would have had more of that effect
for sure I can imagine the people who didn't
know about it were like oh my god um but when
it comes to uh the last one that really was
like holy [__] was I think Spider-Man
far from home sure when Peter Parker and
Jameson and yeah and uh he's Spider-Man yeah
that that was the last one where it was like
everything that just happened has
been completely flipped upside down
I can't wait for this next Spider-Man
movie what are they gonna do yeah that
was the last one where I but now a
lot of times you're like all right
cool yep yeah you need one yeah yeah absolutely
it's just yeah they're requisite now it's like if
you don't get a mid in a post-credits scene now I
feel like you'd walk out going what happened there
um thank you guys again for being here
really means a lot uh Deadshot is asking and
um yeah how intrigued are you about The
Flash movie since Tom Cruise love it
not gonna lie it it does do something outside of
movies are you ready for mk-12 trailers soon oh
Jesus oh boy they're making the new MK how do you
get into the storyline it's been wow uh we got six
sixes uh yeah John you didn't really get a comment
about this I talked about it last stream um so how
do you feel about Tom Cruise loving the flash good
I mean it certainly seems like Tom Cruise is an
agent of Cinema I don't think he has any reason to
do this you know out of a contrivance of any kind
it seems like if he heard it was great and got a
copy and said it was great it's probably pretty
great I don't know like unanimously everyone was
like this movie is great so unless there's some
kind of shadowy conspiracy where people are like
we just need this movie to make money please uh
you know that's very heartening I I think there
is some weight though too about him calling Andy
machete what do you think oh absolutely yeah
I mean that suggests again like if that really
happened I think that's a lovely thing uh because
yeah that that shows especially from somebody like
Tom Cruise I can just imagine he's like no I gotta
let you know how great this is you know and uh
and yeah like and I that makes me really happy
for Andy Mushi Yeti especially because of how
difficult the road this has been and you know like
I am rooting for him to you know level up again
you know with this movie from you know Mama to it
to this so oh he did Mama didn't he am I or was it
Ma no no no no no no but uh but yeah I think mama
is a mushy Eddie joint yeah uh that's right yeah
when he was going by Andres still oh oh yeah back
in the DIA that's right and somewhere along the
line is his publicist in America it's like we need
you to be more of a universally appealing name
we don't want people thinking this
is a Mexican movie we want them to
know Andy's is more relatable than uh
Andres puts you into a corner yes yes
of course that's right it's super Americans
we don't know what to do or like are we gonna
pronounce this wrong is you somehow hoity
toity director right Andy everyone knows
an Andy to this day is his schwartzen
Slimer uh no one knows how to pronounce
Arnold's last name just works in Slimer is
my favorite Ghostbusters character [Laughter]
always watching so good to see you here don't
worry we'll be watching DND Sandman will forever
be on the list maybe when season two comes out
we'll watch it and then have a Witcher experience
where season two ends up being hated uh Netflix
is dark is something that has been considered
for a certain for certain it's been considered
yeah people love dark and they have been taught
I've heard people talk about it consistently for
years yeah yeah I do want to watch it man thank
you oh no yeah at least finish out season four
and let's see how that goes very least we'll see
bigots have started to forget that Civil War was
titled Captain America movie while being Avengers
that's right man I love that um super
soldier ship in the Incredible Hulk girl
my favorite part of live streams when I'm
reading just reading these to myself without
reading them out loud it's okay because now
I'll recite the directors again take it away
John do it super quick okay so the director's
working right now I would say it's Jordan Peele
Robert Eggers Denise Villeneuve ariaster
and Tarantino for the auteur veteran status
and then personals I would go Panos cosmoto's
Danny Boyle John Carpenter Karen kusama right
you say that Tarantino thing as if he's
not an amazing director he is an amazing
director this is one of those pulls it's
an obvious pull that like you know everyone
kind of feels like well of course you
chose Tarantino and Rodriguez a lot
he's really hit or miss he's Hit or Miss but I
like his I I like how him all of it is whereas
like there are certain people who make a miss
and I'm like ah this is just a Nothing Cake where
it's like a Robert Rodriguez Miss is still filled
with flavors sure even if it doesn't work crooked
um my God what is wrong with his Mouse um oh and
one more thing don't want to spoiler for John who
she is but Florence Pugh as Abby in Last of Us
season two please oh my God uh I do like that
pick even though people say she's too old I like
a lot the choice like I was thinking about it when
watching Mandalorian whoever that woman is with
Pershing in episode uh oh yeah yeah um um I don't
know that actress's name but she's great she's
also an Ant-Man quantity oh something I think
she would be a fantastic pick Katie O'Brien I mean
she's got the build and she's very believable and
they're she's got enough quality she doesn't look
a lot like um as Abby but I think she'd be a good
pick but yeah we shouldn't really talk too much
about this uh let's see your city boy is it a boy
uh do you think reverse flash is going
to be in The Flash movie I do not think
reverse flash is going to be in the
movie I don't know maybe it could be
steal the opportunity for Ezra to get to
do that so I think if you do recast Kang
I've seen the question come up a couple of
times in this chat as I've been scrolling
um I think if you do recast King I think you
should keep it with a person of color sure
yeah yeah I don't think you should just make it a
Whitey wood Mighty Mike my Whitey or you go with
um Jody Whitaker uh I would be here for that I
might as well make a king a woman uh I I do think
um I mean you could do Sterling K Brown you could
make it work the cool thing is you could take
someone who's already died in the MCU and then put
them in there because Terence Howard okay Terence
Howard is King what a bold move that would be
holy crap that would be insane all kinds of
questions for wait was Iron Man one in a different
Multiverse okay just hide again the whole time
like why now and then did he have to brainwash
everybody and not realize when the real Rodeo
um wait a minute we do have ourselves Ace One
stream lap to honor here hey we must honor the
stream Lab somebody in the chat just going
back to that disappointed TV shows question
Riverdale I was enjoying up until the point I
stopped watching it so I ca even though I've
heard it goes downhill I I cannot claim that
myself your phone oh your phone's ringing oh
hi John which one okay boom let me just uh
make everything really complicated here do
it the more complicated the better that's what
people say I know we're not jabby Coe uh Sammy
boy thank you so much for the stream Lab hi I
hope you're having a great day you know what
it could be better could be could be
we'll see maybe it will get it I woke up
it's massive um anyway I was wondering since
we are in the reboot long-awaited sequels era
has it been a success in your opinion or just
milking it I feel like Studios don't care if
the script is good if they just get a profit well
I I I mean [__] top gun Maverick is uh sensation
and it's that's such a crowd-pleasing film it
got nominated for an Oscar for best picture and
best screenplay and uh is billion dollar box
office behemoth I feel like that is I mean I
feel like there's been I think this this era has
made it worth it for films such as Top Gun mapper
that's a good way to put that yeah because they're
always Mining and they're always you know coming
back for some Legacy I think right now we're
in an interesting point where you have people
you have the sort of Remaining movie stars who
are also getting older who are now sort of closing
these loops and bringing certain characters
and Stories full circle and I think that is
a bit unique as to as compared to what I've been
aware of in the past at least like even something
like a John Wick 4 feels like sort of some kind
of culmination for movie star Keanu Reeves top
gun Maverick obviously a culmination for movie
star uh Tom Cruise so yeah I feel like we have
that extra element of like emotional maturity
going into some of these but yeah I mean it's
the same milking process it's always
been and sometimes there are gems
all depends but thank you for asking
about that yeah uh let's see here
it's not Steve is is Russell T Davies I think is
taking back over from from chibnol it's not it's
not Stephen Moffett I need to fix this this is
a bob Iger situation how people are treating it
we just started season 11 over on or we just
finished season 11 over on patreon too it wasn't
as bad as everyone said it would be yeah like
the movie pixels Jaime James 13. will you watch
Dungeons and Dragons honor among Thieves well
first off thank you for the Super Chat I saw
it every night with someone I started dating
and we both loved it and then we fell in love
and she made sweet sweet love to me in a Jamaican
accent the entire night and we rolled the 20-sided
dice to decide on position it was all because of
Dungeons and Dragons that's right she would stand
on top of me and snare like a dragon your best
Benedict Cumberbatch and mocap impression yeah
uh we do we are gonna watch it but uh probably
not in the theaters we have a very limited window
for when a movie reviewed as well a very specific
set of circumstances really it's got to be like a
couple days ahead of time it's gonna be outside
it's gonna be a certain caliber of moving it's
gonna be a play Blockbuster of sorts we don't
have uh we're not one of those channels that
does well if we're like ah we released this
Saturday it came out yeah we didn't know well
enough unfortunately but Rick Michonne spin-off
as well as a Daryl spin-off overall thoughts on
Gotham I just want to put that out there uh
I thought Gotham was incredible incredible
um were you guys embarrassed when Eric Voss
said making videos on Jonathan major so soon
was unethical just depends on what the videos were
I think if you watch our videos on it I think we
we I genuinely think we have a pretty fair way
of doing it sure I don't think our videos are
disingenuous and I feel like we're apt to be
like hey it's a little soon to be jumping to
certain conclusions you know so yeah it's really
all in how you handle it I mean some might say or
some people embarrassed when they film a reaction
video when clearly they've already reacted to it
would they already watched it beforehand
you know like it's one way of saying it
uh yeah you know I don't know there's lots of
embarrassing circumstances in the YouTube space
that you could find yourself in uh but Eric
is a genius and I if you haven't seen he's a
really really kind guy um on the way to the
to the live stream that he did here with us
um and also I've seen a couple of his videos for
deep dive and they're great they are great videos
uh the low-key ones pretty [__] amazing and I
really do love the live stream live stream that
uh we did here it's almost like 200 000 views
yeah and it's got like a 45 minute watch time
mark this is the most longest watch Time
video I've ever had so Eric to sit in the
corner always uh we'll review Mario Oppenheimer
and Barbie Mario um I think we're gonna react
reaction I'm gonna react to that might as well
uh Oppenheimer theaters theaters theaters Barbie
real back and forth uh I'm really back
and forth I don't know uh Barbie I'm sorry
feels like a reactor it does but I also I'm
like but Ryan Gosling right in the theaters
you got to see those abs big um yeah I see oh I
see some muscles under that Cape you're good oh
you're right you absolutely are seeing muscles
under that cave Alex see I survived the April
first fits a comic book cast where they all trolls
it can't be they some of them are all they're all
true they're all true April fact day is what
we're celebrating now so John is getting paid
is these oh no you John has mainly been doing this
at the kindness of his heart that's right and this
commitment impoverished I just like being here
negatives and broke for years the IRS is actively
pursuing my whereabouts like how come you bring no
income ever how do you have a straight zero income
constantly at a zero yeah you're not even in the
negative so you're just zero solid zero yeah you
know that's how I do um damn it well thank you for
the Super Chat Alex see yeah leave comment with
your uh favorite of the April 1st comic book cast
April Fool's vids but uh thank you guys again for
I just want to keep saying thank you to everyone
who's here to the chat if you haven't left a like
yet please go ahead and do that if you have to
bounce at any point if I can't stick around for
the whole thing please hit the like that's if
you want to leave here you have to leave a like
and please go ahead and uh Muhammad we are are
factoring out some stuff I I think the more time
goes on with YouTube the more direct and honest
I get advertised I slowly become just more more
I've already been a pretty transparent guy and
then now I'm like even more transparent I think
that's a good policy because then people have a
better idea of what actually goes into all this
um yeah no you can contribute to our patreon
or you can super chat or or get one of our Zero
edition shirts most sold shirt our most recent
one which I I'm still waiting for the mail
um our most recent one uh the child protection
services shirt that is our uh most sold shirt
um ever and it did it in 24 hours uh I was like
normally we look at the 30-day window and it's
like this sold more than any and then the other
one's in 24 hours and that that was really this
is a good feeling I was really proud of that uh
snow Shadows top five Batman villains in order
okay here we go we can do this sure go from
the heart all right I would say uh I'm not sure
let's try to count backwards a little bit here
um look I'll get this out of the way just so
there's no big anticipation here the cliche one is
Joker and number one for me is Joker it is Joker
like at the same time yeah like everyone else I'm
like please stop doing Batman and Joker movies for
a while let us miss the Joker please but there's a
reason Joker is one of the most iconic characters
of all time and why he goes so hand in hand with
Batman like he is the best villain for Batman
and so yeah I love Joker um as much as I want
to pull like odd ones they're all bunch of people
really do know uh I do love Mr Freeze I think Mr
Freeze is an insanely compelling villain and I'll
rearrange the order in just a bit uh Deathstroke
wall can be across the board for a lot of people
I do think Deathstroke for hand-to-hand combat is
pretty incredible Moss is not in love with racial
ghoul the way other people are so I don't know if
I'd even include him on the list um I weirdly like
Mad Hatter Madhatter I like Mad Hatter quite a lot
and there's like okay there's Killer Croc Hugo
it was strange a Hugo Strange is pretty great
okay so I think for five I go Mad Hatter okay
four I go clay face oh fun three I go Mr Freeze
yeah I'm also not like when I read penguin in
comics I'm not that drawn to him okay but I
do like him in on screen a lot sure uh we're
gonna put Hugo straight did everything five
two
oh I forget about the female ones like poison
ivy I love poison ivy I would put poison ivy as
three probably three for me too yeah no you know I
bumper to two Mr Freeze at at three and then I put
um uh Joker at one okay yeah okay oh yeah Joker
uh scarecrow at number two uh poison ivy [__]
did I skip scary I've come up with a whole story
idea surroundings characters I've totally blank
on scarecrow it's all good there's some I think
Batman has a great Rogues Gallery yeah uh yeah
so uh Joker yeah I gotta swap out of Mad
Hatter sure sure uh uh and then poison ivy
this is John list so I'll say
uh Phantasm and Solomon Grundy
nice yeah yeah it's not bad yeah yeah and Phantasm
is great yeah no offender again that's such a
great movie like it's such a lovely wonderful
movie yeah I think he's got a great Rogues Gallery
but they're you know I was trying to answer
like who am I definitely drawn to live action
and Comics yeah and who would I want to play with
if I had the opportunity yeah you know to write
um let's see here this sounds like an April
Fool's joke but I think it's legit Tommy
Wiseau has a film coming out tomorrow called
Big sharp by the way would love to interview
you guys again oh thank you so much formerly peace
oh Spencer what's up buddy um yeah you know I do
I wonder I haven't I've only done my
zone movie I've seen in his room yeah
I haven't seen the other ones because
I always wonder if it's gonna try to be
so bad it's good or is it gonna capture that
lightning in a bottle yeah I thought the house
would drip blood on Alex short was pretty fun but
it is in that sort of like we're embracing the
meme kind of kind of caliber I mean like this is
a a film directed by hymns I think so I mean and
if it's got a shark in it like that's not what I
was expecting at all so I mean I'm excited to see
I haven't seen the trailer yet but I'm excited
to see whatever weirdness comes out of it like
yeah I haven't seen best friends I haven't seen a
lot of his other like random appearances but yeah
I mean if it's him directing I have to imagine
that it's it's gonna it's gonna be tell me why
so Joey I would love to watch it yeah that's true
yeah I like it it seems like it will have to be a
strange and interesting experience no matter what
okay yeah yeah yeah I might watch it who knows
um full reaction maybe that's a big maybe this
is all we gotta check it out giant list of things
yeah let's go in order of and I like doing the
weekly live streams this is the thing that I I
feel I really do enjoy the live streams and and
I want to make it a regular not a daily thing but
like a once a week thing I think it's a really
enjoyable experience and it's kind of like uh
I don't know how to put it it's kind of it's so
there's such a process between filming and editing
and and uh whereas here there is something
that's like a a refresher and a reset of
like a palette cleanser weird way I don't
know for the brain to just do a live stream
because it's it's just so like off the cuff
and personal and yeah well we get to spend
time directly with you not like trying to cut
or insert you know yeah it's such a different
uh it's more I do I do enjoy it it makes it
it's it may it makes feel more connected to
to audience yeah I just love the energy
like live streams are so fun like I'm I'm
grateful to be here today because uh yeah this
is always a highlight to join you guys live on
a on any day of the week Joker scarecrow
Riddler I like Riddler I do like River
I don't know there's something about Riddler
though that I I don't know I'm not I'm not as
in love I love Riddler but I'm not he's not my
top five for some reason it's not the one I'm
like looking for yeah it's strange yeah and I'm
weirdly totally understand why they constantly
want to bring in for Live Action even loved him
in Gotham thought it was excellent like my God
what an underrated performance uh and he was like
a series regular it was amazing and I I understand
why people love him so much but at the same time
um you know there's something about where I'm not
not like always the most even though he's a I
don't know now that I'm I feel like I'm talking
myself into it now because even like the Batman
games and [__] I'm like you know what though
would you get Riddler right like when
you got when you get it right like it's
pretty he's pretty [__] compelling
sure game of mystery and kind of Mouse
um you have to yeah you just have to have
really smart writing around them yeah yeah
all right the more uh this is really easy just
uh watch watch that happen um so let's see here
oh that's a really nice way to put it 99 of the
time when I try to be honest about something like
that PK Production Studios it leads to insane
backfire thank you so much yeah thank you
um tasm II killman when your film was failure
makers can we get a real Rejects movie in the
style of fablemans yes I've always thought it'd
be more like a Michael gandry movie oh sure I
think a real Rejects Move would be more than that
yeah I haven't seen Be Kind Rewind but I imagine
it would be like that from the trailer I remember
being from my vague recollection of I have seen Be
Kind Rewind and yes I think it would be yeah
in in in what I recall of it yeah there does
need to be a level of trust with the audience we
are Jack Black and most deaf I appreciate that um
thank you so much for the Super Chat my
friend thank you again the super chats do
not go underrated I'm under recognized I mean
thank you they're uh definitely definitely do
not take it for granted enough like you're all
like any and all of your generosity is like very
you know none of you have to be here contributing
anything we get messages on patreon and I really
try to respond to everyone and I'm often very
late um but for those who have messaged me on
patreon you'll know that I I do try to respond so
uh thank you do you guys think do you think D guns
DCU will cater for comic book fans who enjoy the
more serious mature stuff like me I've lost that
face with MCU I missed movies like Logan The Dark
Knight and Man of Steel only have Reeves Batman
um
uh you know as much as there is a a reverence
and vulgarity in The Suicide Squad there's also
a lot of maturity to it I think it depends on the
property that being said with the properties that
were announced I I feel like they they
will the voice of it will probably draw
there was this thing that came out recently with
Victoria about Victoria Alonso and then how a
director was talking with this very credible
reporter about how Victoria Alonso pretty much
stated that like the directors don't direct the
movies we direct them and that's something that
I think most of us already picked up on that
it's very committee driven with its films and
there was a great point of how that's why they
pick out these independent filmmakers who have
no experience with visual effects films because
it causes you it's essentially like creating
like a codependent relationship or like we
don't really know what to do so we're going
to trust that you put it together you know
yeah and that's why a lot of them end up kind
of having the same look to them uh not just
in the visual effects but kind of all around
and I think Gunn will let the director's voice be
more of the conversation in conjunction with the
filmmaking I feel like the directors will be part
of the committee yes in a more vital way like just
the fact that he's embracing the elseworld
side off hand and and like embracing Joker
embracing the Batman letting those exist to me
speaks volumes that he will also help allow that
when it comes to I don't think they'll just
let him do whatever but I think I think he'll
help encourage to bring out more of the unique
voice per film yeah I would agree with that yeah
certainly and I think that I I think that
they will definitely cater to and honor the
you know more mature side of the universe but
I think it will just be more in proportion to
what the comics actually are which is you'll
have a lot of stuff that is a little bit more
light a little bit more of aspirational to
younger viewers but you will certainly have
your mature caliber stuff I just don't really
ever foresee it going into the direction again
where anytime soon where it's mostly geared toward
that mature dark gritty kind of tone I feel like
you might not get as much but you will get some
sure sure see the stopwatch helps it does yeah
create a stopwatch when it came to koi doing his
solo videos here yeah Cory we're doing a ranking
video you can't talk for 10 minutes to go through
we could have 200 minute ranking video yeah yeah
yeah but you know I feel like people's flag comic
book things that aim toward the youth and I'm like
that's why they were invented to begin with
and we shouldn't lose sight of that but yeah
also there will be maturity depends per property
I don't think John should play extreme Last of
Us one because I I think that's part of the the
joy of I should wait till the show's done yeah
yeah just to do any of that okay because I don't
think they're gonna continue it um I don't think
they're gonna continue it uh uh after season two
because I think they're gonna divide season two
in a two seasons because the game is forever the
first game is kind of short and the second game is
really low yeah same game is a long time like when
I replayed the first one I beat it in a weekend
and then the second one I was like uh assuming
like at least a week and a half to get through
um one then maybe then maybe by then I'll have
a PS5 to play off over okay seven or whatever
we're on because lately I've been like okay how
do I hook my PS3 up to the TV first streaming
because even though part two is very different
I still feel like the cree it will create a
certain kind of lens of comparison and watching
performance and I think that's part of the joy
of John and Tara's reactions to that is you
don't they they have no true foundations yeah
um did talk about I can't wait for stranger
things season five I don't know who's gonna
die I don't think they like killing off people um
I gave a very long detailed answer MJ to Superman
and Lois coverage yeah can't go through
it again um Andrew mirik ooh interesting
what do you guys think of Grace Randolph's
hate towards Jessica Chastain well thank
you for the Super Chat I think it's funny
yeah I'm gonna report you for child abuse
I I think I think it's funny sure because it's
become a meme in it of itself but I find more
interesting is the James Gunn like I I want to say
this I don't I don't like YouTube beefs and I know
I make fun of like pretty much everyone when it
comes to Grace Randolph we've briefly chatted we
get along and and uh she's been very kind to
to me especially on on all accounts and I've
uh whatever jokes I make just trust me they're
all in fun jest they're never in like I'm trying
to tear this person down and I do that about
a lot of YouTubers but I know Grace Randolph
can often be a Target especially on Twitter
uh but I do find it more fun when I'm like oh
something about James gun disagreeing with
her [__] because yeah he's gonna jump in
there right like so many of these people you
get the sense that this maybe this will get
back to them but I don't know not even that
seems unlikely or is James Gunn he's gonna
be the talking direct well I mean yeah I know
James Gunn has definitely had his issues with
with Grace like he's made some serious and there
was something recently with like Dylan O'Brien
being cast and then he quote tweeted not in a
nasty way he was just saying like I don't even
know who this person is yeah yeah and then he
followed up being like okay okay yeah I looked
him up and I've seen him before but because of
the history of Prior interaction of like a real
insult that he threw at grace before yeah it you
know led to that again she often goes trending
and it's usually not usually for some kind of
controversy but my direct inner any kind of
interaction or even public speaking with her and
I has always been it's been positive so yeah I'm
I don't but I I think the meme itself of Grace
hate Grace Randolph hating to Jessica Chastity
and I I don't I have a weird thing where I have a
very difficult time with um Peter sarsgaard sure
uh sleepy eyes something about him where once
in a while he does a performance from like you
know what you were good I thought you were
one of the best parts of that Green Lantern
movie but more often than not on like more often
than not I'm like I don't get why you get work
he's watching the stream right now he's about
to go tweet you and this is my opinion and I
just made it I made a joke out of it because
it's uh because I know that I'm I I can also
the first movie I saw me was Kenzie but at the
same time I don't I don't have a genuine hate for
the guy sure sure she's a joke to me yeah yeah I
think I I think it kind of borders on uh you know
it's yeah it's just like this guy has his thing
his look and it's not for me yeah yeah which is
uh it's funny enough I know a few people who feel
that way about Jessica's Chastain in particular
daisha's always watching what's up thank you
for for taking a break from John Wick to join us
uh John Wick reaction um always watching what's up
Roby I know we we are divisive here when it comes
to the King Dynasty mid credit scene the idea is
cool the execution is funky um be funky fresh uh
Johnny favorite movie thank you for being here
and for contributing uh favorite movie genre and
favorite movie theater food favorite movie genre
what's your favorite movie genre my favorite
umbrella is horror horror movies of all varieties
are usually My my what I am compelled toward
is that is that what's your
favorite movie theater food Johnny
clap I mean you know we didn't grow up having
the movie theater food so when I started like
really going to the cinema with you and like
you know when I let go of that like just the
Classic popcorn has become such a like when you
get good movie theater popcorn ain't nothing like
it uh but you know aside from that like I don't
know I I I I like the classics I don't I don't
need necessarily like one of those AMC's where
they're bringing you like a four course meal so
it's like if it's not uh popcorn then it's like
a hot dog or a nacho or something like that you
know the classics both times I've seen John Wick
I did not get popcorn and that was tough I know
it's just the hardest I think out of the the
biggest challenge of eating healthier these
past few weeks has been saying no to popcorn
at theaters sure that's been the hardest part
it's such a habit yeah just want to learn but
now I pack like healthy snacks and become that
you become Andrew become that loser you become
Andrew who's like you're like keto cereal yeah
he was a kiwi slice let's go or
whatever it happens to be yeah yeah
um yeah I've become that guy but uh now I sneak
Topo Chicos into the theater but but it is hard it
is hard to say no because I love I love popcorn at
theaters it's a perfect experience yeah especially
when you get a good like that's why I missed
the Arc Light they had such good popcorn and the
Lemley and nose going away they got good popcorn
I remember I think we saw a test screening for Al
Pacino documentary called Salome and I just I have
this weird memory of young Greg and John and their
teens yeah and just looking over at John and how
he was eating popcorn back in the day yeah though
I just get a big handful I gotta Flex me
try to offset the calories by by flexing
it up a little bit never forgotten the image
you're just looking over it's this big I know
and and now whenever I grab like a few kernels
and it's like you know you get that that that
finger full where like there's just unwieldy
kernels sticking to each other and now I'm
like am I going back to that away it was like
a cartoonishly like you put a guy in a fat suit
yeah man you've taught me how to eat theaters
you've taught me how to breatheners he really
shaped me as a movie goer and I appreciate
it it's for the better of all audiences
40x screenings lately and it is it is surprisingly
hard to keep a hold of popcorn in that environment
I love the AMC commercials people with their
popcorn yeah yeah at that point if I'm leaning
in I'm not going to be like eating much more
you're not going to be hugging the barrel my
freshman or when they're watching a
film in the trailers something spooky
happens I'm like I've never done that
today I don't think I've ever even seen
that happen yeah they have infomercial
hands where just like anything happens
and they're just like whoa the popcorn it's
everywhere I just dump it on the person yeah
it looks magical
yeah man and uh and of course uh just I love
people applauding I feel like you know uh they
gotta next time have uh what's her name
correct Nicole kimmons she doesn't eat
at the theater she's not throwing her popcorn
she'll take after Nicole I know she rents out
the whole theater like a [__] like an
elite this is the best way to experience
thousands of dollars for Sam the manly thanks to
the Super Chat Charlie Sheen is Wolverine that'd
be nuts oh cool uh Sam the man lean you're all's
list from cameos for Secret Wars I could list this
off in five seconds everyone everyone will be in
secret Wars it'll be at the point where if they're
not in it the movie will be rendered disappointing
I'm thinking get Dolph Lundgren's Punisher yeah
in there oh Hasselhoff's Nick Fury yeah now I'm
serious do it do it all just make room for just
one giant spinning shot yeah so Eric Voss can
have a field day of trying to point everyone
out Italian Spider-Man all of it do it I'm not
even kidding just usually one shot who played
Captain and they're all Canon Captain America
movie just one shot everyone kind of Tom Cruise
Iron Man do it one shot yeah that's all you need
yeah yeah um thanks babe for letting me now uh doe
eyes who do you think will be revealed as a scroll
and oh no oh no John have we lost it oh no oh no
no no John no no no no no oh we
got it we got it we're good oh
we think we'll Beville is a scrolling secret
Invasion everyone Tom Cruise Iron Man Nick Fury
David Hassel uh you mean that's part of the fun of
the secret Invasion comic run to my understanding
so who's been a scroll all this I think I think
the game will be of like who's the scroll will be
more so and people who are introduced as humans
in in the episodes or whatever or like oh is
this is this new computer interaction we're
having is right now is that the actual thing
I think it's going to be more of that cat and
mouse game or whatever new humans are introduced
yes or is this an actual authentic character is
this a scroll I feel like yeah like there might be
maybe one or two where it's like all this time
they've been a scroll or something but I don't
know I feel like that would be hard to justify
with any of the characters who have had solo
movies yeah you know because then it would make
that it would create a weird canonical gap for
people I think if we do too much of that you know
I think it's going to be way more I don't think
it's going to be as the what's the one part that
I think people are kind of expecting when you hear
secret Invasion but I to my understanding it's
probably going to be a lot more streamlined and
really focused on fleshing out the Scrolls as
characters where you're going to have like one
Camp because if I'm not mistaken I've heard
some of the information from the Vanity Fair
article uh I didn't read the whole thing yet
but that yeah picking up from Captain Marvel
were Nick Fury promised them a home uh that has
not clearly happened for them and that Amelia
Clarke is the daughter of Talos and apparently
she was like whoever the little girl scroll was
in Captain Marvel okay there's not a rumor this
is [__] with Samuel Jackson said whoever the
little girl was that's who's grown up and then
she has kind of a resentment towards Nick Fury
exactly and and then some tension with her
father as well so it's kind of like you do
have some factions here go occurring with them
uh because I'm sure Talos is not bad and I'm sure
even the bad scrolls are probably not going to be
portrayed as super villainous yeah but they just
have a different philosophy and feel unfairly true
they need a home you know I'm sure we'll unders
I'm sure they'll do some acts that we don't agree
with but I I I'm under the impression they're not
going to fully portray them as just like they are
villains or maybe they get to episode eight and
then they just do that yeah yeah yeah and then
they commit a mass murder yeah yeah they'll be
they'll be like the more agreeable version of the
flag Smashers from uh the portrayal of the flag
it's a show right not a movie secret Invasion
yeah is the show yeah okay it is the show and
then Secret Wars is the most yeah I know I
don't see your words I just been making sure
sure because there's sometimes I see people
say movie and I'm like wait a minute what yeah
yeah um yeah no it's a series Carlos we answered
this my friend Jason Momo wasn't wrong about
the Snyder cut Richard Nixon I have been working
out oh thanks for joining and you're not a crook
and it's going to be a six episode series no doubt
well well we can't spoil John Wick in here move
past this fast whoa no John Wick spoilers protect
John Wicked all cops I do think they should end it
I know I saw that that I don't know if it was an
April Fool's headline but that's just sort of like
the sheer amount of money is making them consider
a John Wick five and I'm like no no no just leave
it for right now just let it be come back in
10 years we can't I can't do it yeah already
70. yeah and then try it but yeah for right
now it's such a beautiful piece just let it be
Let It Be gonna need a gun I'm gonna need
a cortisone injection going to kill you
I filed my AARP I need to go to the doctor
he's always confused in that movie prostate
is swollen pretty sure I have internal
bleeding uh that's these bones are much
mushrooms I think the lines he does best in
that movie are when the lines are written like
questions yes and then he takes declarative
sentences and then turns those into questions
gonna kill you [Laughter] [Music]
yeah you're gonna start a war just give me a gun
I really enjoyed this format it's very chat
inclusive oh good uh yeah it took a while to
figure out how to best to incorporate the chat
but we love you guys we want you to feel seen
and heard touched and felt and fondled and then
sue us and then yes show us something tall or the
real rejects touched your soul nfx visuals have
you guys checked out Barry hobo thank you for
the Super Chat I highly recommend it stars Bill
Hader and Henry Winkler oh Greg loves him a berry
to me is one of the best television shows
of all time and I do not say that lightly
Bill Hader is I'm gonna look up has he should
be clay face is he he would be a great Clayface
um is he directing any movies because there
are episodes where I'm like you are one of
the best directors I've ever seen like add
that to the list uh best directors working
right because I just don't know of any movies
he's directed I mean has he directed any movies
for acting oh yeah because if you
guys haven't seen Barry it is this
there's no real way to describe Barry it
starts off like as an LA Noire dark dramedy
but then it just sometimes turns into the coolest
action [__] you've ever seen there's this
there's this Chase sequence in season three
done with no music on like that goes into the
highways and neighborhoods it and it's no music
the entire time and it is so gripping and intense
and it's a bill hater directed episode oh I'm
excited and you could you you feel like they
let they you really let them direct the episode
you don't it's not controlled here's the right
um and then uh yeah go to the director he's only
directed for Barry and there's no upcoming that's
what I mean I'm like when's he gonna direct
a film it's gonna happen he is a phenomenal
director and he's directed like so much of Perry
yeah the pilot was written and directed by him
um I think I think so uh vitally impressive
either way I mean even if it wasn't I mean the
fact that once you get to like what season three
or four it's like he's directing it all and it's
a great character study and and it's odd but it
it never feels like the show is in conflict or
trying to come up with something and it it there
are some of the funniest [__] I've ever seen on
television and some of the most intense moments
I've ever seen like it there's nothing like Barry
is great and I'm keeping it for me I'm
not gonna react to it all right it's not
opening mines it would be a good reaction
John all right if there's have you not
seen it no I've only seen one part of an
episode have you ever seen any of Barry
not really oh my God it's like the best thing ever
I mean I might have watched the pilot way back and
I and I saw a piece of an episode where there's
this Barista who keeps giving people advice it was
very funny yeah it's fine season three yeah yeah
but but yeah I haven't seen much at all of Barry
um Cruz Rivera that's that's one of those
shows where I'm like I want to watch this on
a consistent basis so I can really take in and and
yeah so I've been like saving it for some I love
that it is a phenomenal and they're and they're
and they're short seasons and the average episodes
only a half hour oh yeah cool like they they keep
that [__] tight um but it's great uh yeah Cruise
the next season is the last season and I think
and I'm glad it is it should be the last season
yeah it seems like it's staying just right along
as it means weird day and age where we end things
on a four yeah cruiservera do you think Seth
Rogen thank you for Super Chat Metrology time
second one do you think Seth Rogen my God what
is wrong with this Mouse uh as and Evan Goldberg
could Helm a Marvel DC property they're basically
the John Favre of Amazon Prime and TMNT yeah I do
I think it'd be a great addition to anything I
mean they could be a new James Gunn when it comes
to like preacher and the boys like they and they
really know Comics sure especially Seth Rogen they
really know Comics I I feel like they be I don't
think they should do Marvel I feel like they'd be
a fantastic addition to the DC Universe though
sure yeah the the that's the the riper fit yeah
if they were gonna do a Marvel I feel like they
would have to do a special kind of what if he kind
of project yeah something where they can direct it
themselves I mean it might be too similar to boys
I mean they're not the same thing um but something
like Authority I'm like that might be a cool Seth
Rogen Evan Goldberg property yeah I mean they
can certainly do it you give them Booster Gold
um would you like to see bad batch live action
at Mando no because I think it spoils the fate
and future of them for me sure um whoa that's
interesting music I had a chance Nora from Miami
hey Nora Nora the writing of Avatar 4 is writing
Fantastic Four yeah oh yeah I saw that I think the
um I think the addition of this writer
is great because he's worked more on like
serious sci-fi projects like epics yeah not the
writers who they who they had before which did
like funny stuff they were more like animated
comedy yeah this is like snow piercer and
[__] yeah this is more this this will give it
a different type of sci-fi heft to it I I believe
yeah I think it's heartening actually as much
as people think it's a good pick I think it's
a really good pick for Fantastic Four yeah it's a
good pick and I think as much as people have been
panicked hearing certain things like this like
oh they're rewriting blade oh they're rewriting
Fantastic Four I'm actually happy about that
because it shows that they're paying attention
to one of the most important parts of the
process of these movies that they haven't
been nailing lately which is the scripts yeah
so good news um and there are other writers I'm
sure some of their work will make it in there yeah
Andreas we have shopzeroedition.com for our [__]
Jump On It for our poops uh did you hear about the
Scott Pilgrim versus the world they're making an
anime at Netflix with all of the original movie
cast anyway and I believe the comic uh Creator
is uh behind it as well yeah we're gonna do it
man we're gonna watch it we're gonna react to
it I'm excited let's do it we'll have read all
the Scott Pilgrim novels and I don't love that
movie like everyone else I feel like that's maybe
the last I liked last night in SoHo a lot I like
baby driver but I feel like Scott Pilgrim does
that come before worlds then that might be the
last one I I loved you just there's something
about that movie that like I love parts of it
I do they're they're elements that I really
love Yeah but overall I'm like yeah I like it
but I'm not I'm not everyone else when it comes
to that movie yeah that's for sure but everyone
I know like that movie you've got a hardcore like
people beat that [__] up Daniel Salazar time is
it John okay fairly soon what's up from Miami
well what's up from your Super Chat what do you
guys do you guys think we'll play Doctor Doom
in the MCU I want them to cast them so we can
stop getting this question Daniel I'd love to see
Killian Murphy the writer from Avatar 2 is gonna
play doctor Dooms I think Bill Hader should
play I would love that Doctor Doom [Laughter]
two different voices he's one of the best voice
ever yeah I know I know I know I'm just trying
to imagine his bill hater voice actual bill haters
yeah um who's like a different pick Bill Skarsgard
uh Ron Pearl I think if they go old they should
go Clancy Brown CB is he's he's he's in that
position now where you're like yeah you need
a heavy but who can do kind of the range and
play in the middle of morality get Clancy
Brown I'm glad he's getting his flowers Mr
Krabs deserves it well I think you're you're
a little more used to Clancy Brown in these
like powerful almost Regal like roles now yeah
I've seen some of his work from when he was like
much younger but like he was essentially the main
bad guy in Dexter the reboot and he's like a very
he does great in that and they're like for
a lot of this the show he's just like the
the like a nice guy and uh okay yeah he's great
he's excellent in that and it's very different
than what I'm used to seeing him cast as which
is like show up his stupid conditions totally
totally that's cool oh yeah I'm glad there was
at least something of value in that last uh
do you think Beau and dim will share the throne
yeah you get this half let's just get off my
half yeah off my house just squeezing in here man
yeah just squeeze your butt on the side of there
uh yeah I I hope sorry [__] Ramirez just said
I Jonathan Byers they need to give Jonathan Byers
some things if they don't I think that will be a
general a genuine like markdown for this series
if they don't pay off Jonathan in a satisfying
way thank you Annie Castro nice to see you here
love you and your comments Tony Koto good choice
for Supergirl in the Supergirl movie if they don't
go with the actors from The Flash and yet on it's
actually Anya Anya Taylor Joy would be interesting
yes she would and I mean she she's blonde so
I could see it I don't necessarily see her her
as super girl though I would cast her as other DC
characters first but then again I don't know would
you cast her yeah why not why not fine she's good
she's in a lot of stuff I wouldn't be like excited
necessarily I would want to be taken a little
by surprise I guess like there's something with
people's careers when you do get to the point
where you feel like you see them like too much
yeah yeah totally and you do get to that point
and I think Ryan Gosling if there's one thing
you can credit that guy for doing he really
knows how to sep like give you time away from
him yeah totally because there was one year
there's the year he blew up he had Drive Ides
of March right and Crazy Stupid Love three very
different movies three very different performances
and then he started to catch on to there might
be getting too much uh people were memeing me all
yeah yeah I'm becoming everyone's Bae I need to
step back then he took a wild break came back gray
man now there's another period yeah Barbie like I
I think he he's really smart about that yeah where
you don't feel like you get too much Ryan Gosling
sure and I feel like people could take notes from
that yeah somehow he really he really knew to do
that yeah like early like early on to like with
the sensation rise of him sure um and I need to
say other Joy's like almost or I'm like she hasn't
given me a bad performance but uh but it is like
I see you a lot now she is she is one of like the
short list of names that comes up especially if
it's like a blonde character I mean at the point
where she's playing Princess Peach you're like
okay yeah I mean we're pretty much there you know
uh I mean yeah she's gonna enjoyed all of
her performances thus far I think she would
be a good a good one I think she would
be great I'll be I'd be curious to see
her bulk up and we haven't really got given
her like those really big action role yet
I saw most of it oh that's a John answer I
haven't seen any of it I was I watched it
on the plane and then the plane landed when
there was 15 minutes left oh no you'll never
know how it ends so I to this day I'm like
I don't know how that movie ends how does
Jonathan Byers oh sorry I I meant to say will up
above but yeah how does Jonathan Byers and Arya
Stark and and you know the witch get out of
it I don't know I don't remember the movie um
um oh here we go um hey guys what do you think
we created a greater disruption to the world
order Trump being re-elected president or koi
actually disliking something is probably koi
probably koi yeah if you if you just like came
out and like truly panned something uh I think
people would be out in the streets looting koi is
a wildly unhealthy association with the internet
he's got such a strong opinion about internet and
comments and feedback and Twitter and he's always
like so engaged with it he's like well use this
fuel work out I'm like you're just justifying
your your excuses for this addiction is the
toxicity side yeah yeah you're just addicted
to the conflict is like you're used to be so much
happier because it's like but no I mean I I think
koi can dislike sort of things that yeah but he's
more respectful too as well um when it comes to
disliking something I think he does a good job
in handling disliking something yeah because
um he's never dog piling on something or or
like unless you put him in a spoiler talk
sure yeah but but usually it doesn't seem
like he takes joy and yeah so it's it's a
more sober portrayal of the negative opinion
than just like oh man I [__] hated this
you know yeah yeah and a good respect
for all the work that goes into these
things as as somebody who engages with
so many people involved with all these
things I get the sense that yeah he has a
good amount of respect for the undertaking
I missed the Arc Light I do too yeah
man missing it it's classic theater I
drove past the Cinerama Dome just recently and
and shed a tear a single tier a popcorn tear
Muhammad knew the Salome if we were talking about
that's right Christian unpronounceable Mephisto
definitely he's here he's with all of us he's
in the details you know there's something about
after all that one division stuff I'm like you
know what I'm not even excited from Mephisto
anymore and once it gets here it won't live up
to any of the weird Madness that that you know
brought us what I wish hat didn't I wish they
didn't reveal that mephisto's coming yeah so
far out because imagine you're watching ironheart
which is the show you expect from Fisto to show
up sure but imagine you're watching ironheart and
then Mephisto suddenly appears it'd be like what
this is happening he's here yeah yeah yeah I mean
they can't it's so hard for them to keep anything
secret now but also I guess I appreciate when they
try because then you if you if you have people
leaking stuff like you understand that that's
just part of the thing but like for them just
to be like no he's coming I mean they don't they
managed to get the Quicksilver with Evan Peters
like a week before it came out like a week before
the episode premiered yeah they're this close yes
same thing with uh the the cameos and Multiverse
of Madness yeah so like a couple days before yeah
it's a real bummer it was the day of the premiere
uh-huh that's when it came out that when it went
to the premiere sure it's like oh god oh no
yeah yeah the cat's always gonna come out of
the bag but yeah it would be nice not to know I
mean I've heard that that rumor about what the
Mephisto project could be and if there's any truth
to that it sounds like fun but also I would much
rather be shocked yeah yeah especially after all
the build up and fan out uh hubbub uh John Wick 4
and I'm see I'm glad that's one of the reason
we're talking about the sound design watching
it in IMAX with the sound design and picture oh
yeah yeah I don't regret waiting I don't regret
skipping waiting to react to it here I really I
love that movie I think it's a masterpiece yeah
it is and and and like one of the most like
it's Taylor Made for the IMAX experience like
the IMAX experience is so Exquisite they didn't
shoot it on IMAX cameras but I do understand you
get that right perfect seed and you get to take
in the picture yeah because I think like Dolby
would be more comfortable especially for the
the run time uh to like sit open their feet
you know like that sounds way more comfortable
for for that than this IMAX has this weird thing
where they're like how do we make our seats really
uncomfortable for everyone [Applause] and I'm like
every one of them looks like a space station
now I'm like how did you not get the cushy
chairs yeah there's something about specifically
IMAX where they go we don't need to give them
comfortable seats do we I wonder if it's like a
cost concern of like you know it's a specialized
theater we only have like one of them per year
usually only at like one of them per series of
screens so maybe to get enough people in these
are the chairs that make it so that we can fit
enough I don't know but I do I but I still love
IMAX I love like if I'm gonna watch Oppenheimer
on IMAX I am so excited gonna watch ghost uh not
Ghost Protocol dead Nations I'm gonna watch that
on IMAX like there are certain movies where no
matter what I'm watching IMAX however there's
I'm gonna be a little more selective now that if
I'm like well I do want to watch some theaters but
I'm going to Dolby because because sometimes the
IMAX seats are are not the most comfortable sure
um although I will say the least comfortable way
to experience John Wick chapter 4 is in 4dx did
you watch it in 40x yeah I joined my friend and
it was the kind of thing where he was like I'm
going you want to come and I'm like you know
I gotta I gotta see it again let's do this you
know and and I haven't seen you a while let's do
this and he was like yeah okay 40x and I almost
didn't go because I was like I know already that
this is going to be too much for this experience
and it's gonna be like I'm gonna probably be
working against the the experience to enjoy
the movie and it was a bit like that because I
would hate that because they do calibrate those
chairs to really go hard and so like it's
just like you're sitting there getting beat
up for three hours and like you know when cars
crash or anybody shoots anybody it's just like
and like yeah you spend the whole time just
trying to like activate your core so you can
offset the motion and just see the screen and
I was like this was still a terrific fit like
the film is so good that I still loved it and
had a great time but I was like the this kind
of movie I will probably skip in 4dx yeah well
sometimes 40x can make you focus on your chair
yeah totally and what's happening in this vicinity
then the movie when it's supposed to be a seamless
immersive experience yeah where it's enhancing it
but that is uh you're just getting pummeled it's
like it it elevated quantumania and it and it was
the right experience for that it was the perfect
immersive fantasy but for something like John Wick
it's just like dark serious a lot of violence yeah
it's just like you're just getting pummeled
jinx916 thank you so much for the Super Chat
um what am I trying to say today John would you
guys be up for watching the expanse or have you
or have any of you watched already it's been
recommended me several times I I've known almost
nothing about it but it's been recommended to me a
number of times that I know a lot of people really
love it maybe so it might be I mean it's been a
couple of I I have a list of again criteria is
how interested are we in actually just watching
it so I never covered Severance and then someone
I think it was Michael Tessler told me the
plot of severance and I was like yeah what is
it about damn I don't even know what it's about
and then uh and will our audience be interested
in it and I have a solid third one but and it's
kind of I keep forgetting what that one is but uh
there is a three criteria of it oh Oh you mean our
interest the audience interest and then just the
the exchange of value for time yeah what is the
will it attract new people too will it be a reach
will it grow will it reach out yeah Beyond yeah
yeah the couple people asking for it I believe
Val is in secret Invasion yes I would I would
imagine so I don't know this mustache girl Amazon
commercial nor do I we should get Goose back in
secret Invasion hope so it's the best character
Goose oh we got two back-to-backs our Rambo Rio
Rambo thank you so much for the Super Chat and
thank you guys who have left a like so far do you
think Monica would be in secret invasion I mean I
the sound stands the reason that she would appear
in secret Invasion yeah maybe a scroll version
though I think we'll get [__] like that sure
you know I don't think they do something like
Chris Evans here what cap is just back yeah
no I I think we'll get a few Legacy fake outs
as Scrolls I think we'll get yeah some I think
it's it's more likely yeah that you'd see like a
Val or a moniker or something in here yeah and I
would be very much open to that I'm very excited
and with the involvement of you know coming out
of Captain Marvel anyway and then you've got the
Marvels I feel like even though secret invasion is
not like the connective tissue there's certainly
ample opportunities given that you know uh
Universe Connie sang Thank you so much for
being here Connie my dear I miss you too miss you
guys have a great weekend Connie I am not seeing
anyone this weekend there's so much to get done
right after this stream low kids and tomorrow I
there's no like is one of the weekends we're like
I'm not seeing anyone I got gonna get a lot done
um so yeah but I I'm sometimes people think like
I'm prioritizing hanging out with other people
I'm like the truth is I haven't really gone out
before so Connie uh we have to see you again soon
but thank you thank you everyone's contributed
to the super chats again and also thank you to
everyone who's left a like is that you have you
left a like yet upcoming horror movies you're
most excited for oh easily my answer that I
think Josh is going to steal from me is Evil
Dead rise and saw 10. that's right and uh can't
wait for us to watch a certain movie here on the
Channel that I will not name oh sure you'll keep
you'll see it yeah um but John what about you
uh I want to see Ari Astor's new
movie oh Bo is afraid sure yeah
um that's all the spookums that I've worried
about right now I'm like are there any other
there must be I'm sure uh but yeah the shark the
Tommy wise though shark movie obviously yeah yeah
meg2 meg2 my favorite uh movie and then Meg
two uh the same weekends they can duke it
out they should give Megan too like a crazy
title like dawn of the Megan's Megan Rising
uh uh uh yeah what's uh what's the number
number based pun you can do that's the thing
Megan unplugged yeah but the G's are all fives
I do love that movie I thought Megan was a blast
yeah Mega was really fun Megan Megan is like the
right kind of not Blockbuster budget but you know
one of them it's one of those really Snappy
pop horror movies I have way more fun with
that than cocaine bear uh in a different it's
more madcap certainly in a weird way it's like
throughout it's just kind of wild I think I think
the scenes in between the violins are just like
it's it's fun I think it's more fun movie sure
and it has a little more build to it yeah it's
a little more unified and consistent there I'm
excited to see Patrick Wilson's Insidious movie
that he's directing oh yeah that's right yeah
and they're I need to get a surgery [Laughter]
I need to go to the further I need
to shoot a ghost I hope that oh my God I want this
movie I hope that there are sequel to the nun can
do that thing that all of their spin-off movies
do where the first one is kind of crappy and then
the second one they get some kind of upcomer to
make a great version and then there's the there
I feel bad about that because I really like the
director when we got to meet him he was so nice
I know of course they're nice well and he's he's
uh he's doing stuff like he's he's he's out there
you know hustling and kicking ass so I'm happy
for him because I liked his Direction on that
movie but uh but yeah and then I guess the other
one I'm curious about is uh as much as I am very
mixed on David Gordon Green's Halloweens he's
doing an exorcist so we'll see how that goes
we'll see let's say hey Mark Leach one of our
patrons and just a good friend shouts out to
Mark Leach and to core and Hardy hi Coran Hardy
watches this channel seven maybe do Severance
one of these days I don't is it worth just not
knowing what this setup is probably because I
just keep hearing it's amazing does it do well
for other people sometimes that helps to tell
Severance a great metric episode one reaction
[Laughter] the harmony
because there are some times where it's like oh
wow this person's breakdown did
amazing but reaction I don't know
yeah it doesn't look like it's doing that great
this is like a huge show I thought it was
like an insanely huge show I mean it it's
just the one this is just the one where it like
the people who watch it are very such a passion
for it I've heard a lot of people reference it in
multiple sphere it's not just people like who are
you know spending time talking about movies and TV
all day that I've heard this from so that gives me
some kind of hope that it is truly a standout
um but I don't know too like uh does everybody
have Apple TV plus I feel like that's that's like
a small amount yeah like my yeah my folks have it
but like they they have it to watch Ted lasso
but I like I don't have it man I hear there's
a lot of like great stuff there but I don't have
it yeah and they're and they just you know sort
of committed to doing theatrical movies too now so
I mean they're certainly On The Rise I mean they
their work gets a lot of respect yeah I've heard
even shrinking is great people are going nuts for
shrinking right now I've heard and I had an exact
show idea about that I know do you remember that
idea I called it Henry's patience yeah [Music]
exactly yeah I thought it was a clever title yeah
because he's lost patience with his patients yeah
perfect I thought it was I thought and that was my
exact show idea and then I saw the trailer I was
like oh but this looks fun sure Harry Harrison
Ford's great in it real three R1 okay thank you
so much for being here my friend running around in
different live streams to show my appreciation for
the hard work you guys do for our enjoyment love
you boss voice uh yeah I hope you contributed
more to ours than everyone else's though yes
that's what counts most that's what counts most
yes we we directly rank you all based on that hey
guys are you watching succession if so what are
your thoughts on the episode of the new season
I don't even know what succession is about I know
what succession is I've heard like White Lotus is
great I've heard successful session is great yeah
there's a lot of shows that I'm just behind on we
I mean we've obviously been doing a lot more movie
reactions yeah because you know like sometimes it
can be bad when you're like oh crap we're stuck
with the Witch season two and no one's watching
this video no one likes this anymore and we just
did all this ketchup on the first season yeah
although at least the season two hype helped
out the season-wise yeah but it's a nicer to
catch up on movies honestly I love I love ketchup
the movie reactions have been more of the actual
like you know it's less of a bump like you
think about it from RN too like we did ICU
um which is not doing well at all abuse um
I love our video I do I genuinely love our
video really enjoyed the movie nice surprise um
but it's easier to be like oh this one thing did
not do well yes instead of oh no we're here
at like we have a 10-week commitment yes yeah
yeah I mean which which has happened yeah and so
like beyond that too it's just nice to you get
more variety with the movies like we're like
they're doing like Disney Dreamworks animated
movies horror action you know like we're
doing there's more variety and I like it
um yeah as far as you can hear about uh
attack on title man can't wait for that
Bucky Barnes thanks for holding down the chat
my friend Fanta so nasty do you thank you for
the Super Chat do you guys think Blue Beetle
would with brown one of the big what what the
hell was this question is it supposed to be will
be one of the biggest and newest gross oh film
I thought there was like some weird Mexican joke
here I was wondering that as well yes like oh God
do I participate in this hey do it am I just
racist for inserting that into my own brain
this is your psychology is bare naked
I'm trying to prevent racism have I
inadvertently become racist yeah it's
over since sensitivity racism there you
go do you think Blue Beetle will be one of the
biggest and newest grossing films from DC no
um yes I I'm holding out hope for Blue Beetle
because there's a lot of interesting things
you could do for Blue Beetle uh I I think
that you know first off Latin character
right yeah Jaime uh Jaime Reyes I think that is
a great and imagine the rest of the cast too well
or at least the game out of it oh wait we got
one we got the lead all right don't get don't
get cocky I'm not super familiar with Blue Beetle
I've I'm more like yeah I've played the Injustice
games I've seen my other animated mediums as well
sort of com runs I've read that he's appeared in
but I've never been the one to like I'm gonna
read just a dedicated Blue Beetle comic but I
think with his power sets and stuff that would
be fantastic to bring to live action uh there's
a lot of really fun things I think they got
the perfect guy to be playing Jaime Reyes
as well and you can make it fun and I magically
capture that energy from that first shazam movie
um and that's and so I think I feel like it could
it could actually and the fact that they're doing
Booster Gold who Blue Beetle uh blue and gold
the fact that they're doing the Booster Gold
movies announced I I think helps give reassurance
that this is going to be connected to the James
Gunn DC Universe and not just be like yeah I
like your one movie start again this will not
be the New Mutants of the DC here yeah yeah
I feel like it'll actually be connected but
um I think it'll be a a reasonable hit I don't
think it'll be one of the biggest though I think
it'll be a good hit I think yeah it'll do I think
the first Shazam is probably a solid metric I
think it will succeed hopefully on the merits uh
like them boosting it to theatrical is a good sign
that they have a lot of faith in its quality so I
feel like the word of mouth will help because I do
like Shazam has certainly comic book clout and
knowledge but I feel like for a lot of people
we are getting into a point where we are going
into the deeper recesses of these catalogs of
characters so that your layperson might be like
Blue Beetle what is this sounds like a hodgepodge
character or Shazam what is a Shazam you know
so I feel like the strength of the movie will
dictate that and yeah hopefully it will be
a solid success that can then be built upon
true thank you thank you for that why does
Ryan look adorable on the cape because Ryan
looks adorable without the cape you should
see him in just the cave you should see me
naked okay it is very often naked we'll do a
naked live stream people will be like Greg you
look like you've been gaining muscle you're
like yeah I know right with the right shirt
and everything Greg looks good he was mad
Greg takes the shirt off it's a long time
not living up to my imagination right now
Greg sure sure of just like keep my shirt
um Bucky Barnes my friend I appreciate you guys as
always leave a like reject Nation you leave a like
everyone I don't know why that was like an insult
back if you leave uh if we get to to 5 000 likes
we'll do a naked the 10 000 naked live stream uh
okay you know what with nothing but Jesus Real
Steel is one I'm constantly back I feel like I'm
gonna love that I love Sean Levy and I feel like
he's a very under recognized director um and and
so I want to watch it I do I feel like Real Steel
will be pretty good but I got it I gotta I got a
certain boxing movie I gotta get done this week
Oh yeah and when it's just a VOD release that
takes a lot more editing to make sure that
[__] ain't blocked I'm not talking like one's
well no I'm streaming much easier to deal with
copyright issues and blocks but when it's just
VOD I'm like okay let the games begin I gotta
make sure this doesn't get blocked and I gotta
make sure I got the audience watching this for
a good amount of time yeah um yeah don't worry
don't worry uh let's see nothing much happens
uh I don't watch wrestling I would like to and
I know so many people who love it and I love
their enthusiasm and uh yeah I would love to
take the time I want to do a little experiment
here because I've noticed that we've had a
little bit more lady attention when it comes to
um and for people asking John and Roxy have done
Ip Man too oh yeah it man who's coming pairing
up John with with the women for the big reaction
you're doing Last of Us with Tara are you gonna
do put some boots and rocks to you sure uh what
are some of the should we collaborating with Roxy
um yeah I'm like let's do the experiments let's
try Jennifer's Body out roxycut that is that is a
very fun react I love that that's that's where we
go let's try trolls I love just we're listening to
you guys try to decipher the Diablo Cody dialogue
so okay even cocaine bear has a 13 viewership of
female which is kind of unheard of for us for at
Elizabeth what are some other horror movies that
we've covered I'm running an experiment here okay
um try barbarian barbarian smile okay I want to
see what like because I feel like weirdly enough
like okay that has an oh see Barbarian 19 female
okay normally our numbers are like 90 minutes it's
a barbarian surprise okay okay let's try to smile
because I don't know any of this and I and
I I just I like to study analytics to kind
of gauge some things smile 20 nice all right
that's a great that's crazy that's beautiful
for us yeah that's crazy here's one go back to
mid-summer mid-summer or mid-summer however you
say I still don't know what I mean that's
kind of old um two years ago but it's it's
Queen flow like like let's let's check the
recent versus the old or or you could try 23
23 that's great 23 you're next that's a that's
a female lead okay your next was not did not
perform well okay your next did not perform
well but let's see what the audience is at
14. okay so it seems like seems like when it comes
to the horror movies weirdly attract is normally
it's like oh if we do like a Disney or animated
movie like yeah we'll attract more of a female
audience um but yeah 26 for the black phone really
yeah that's that's crazy yeah dude apparently
there's like a weird thing horror movies because
uh I'm always surprised when the horror movies
have like a good CPM like how much does YouTube
pay per like uh yeah it's a weird conversion thing
guys how much does YouTube pay per woman watch
yeah but they've always said that oh check Megan
Megan recharge that's good I like that as a title
Sinister is 13 and a half but that's a male lead
I feel like there is maybe something to be said
for the female leads as well in these movies
black phone's not female now that it's true though
yeah it's Ethan Hawkins okay Megan is 38.6 percent
that's pretty nuts because Norm I never would have
suspected that yeah and there is a weird like we
don't really set out to be like we gotta get more
of a feel like we don't really set out to that
um but it is just so funny to see like even
Aisha is commenting on the ICU reaction yeah
um it's just funny to see like oh who would have
thought that because because YouTube actually
this is weird thing where they they give you a
higher CPM generally if it attracts more of a
female audience I don't know why that is but
they do I feel like YouTube in general maybe
just do it I I wonder what the average demo of
just all YouTube viewers is and if it is more
male skewing and thus maybe those female views
are just and so it's kind and then whenever I
see comments in our live streams of of of uh
horror a lot of the time they're coming from
um the the female honey inside so I just
wanted to check really quick and I was like
oh damn there's something about the horror
movies that tap into that guess what train
to Busan is what yes just take a guess 40
close 37.4 wow really yeah that is wild to me
true that good to know I know that makes one
because we've been wanting to do more like I
love horror I think I write is generally horror um
but anyway let's get back to Kingdom reactions 25
really yeah I just yeah all right let's get that
uh we are on the sixth season of my hero Academia
and we are loving the [__] out of that show yes
Deku versus classic it might be the best season
they've ever done yeah it's really beautiful like
the first half takes place all in just this one
chunk of time and then the second half is like
some of the most intense and the the challenges
that are posing to the ideologies I think is
genius I love it we're covering our patreon
even though patreon now is it being threatened
for anyone who's been doing uh anime reactions
I'm like great this was supposed to be the safe
space and now now you guys are here to take it
all away yeah we got to kind of move a little
quick through this because we do have to wrap up
um and uh yeah uh okay Marseille Productions
movie reactions have been awesome thank you
so much appreciate the support via the super chat
too that means a lot buddy Johnny Ronald McDonald
versus Burger King from the commercial let's do
this wait what is that actually a commercial uh
is it do they get the creepy ass King who
I love or is that Epic Rap Battles I mean
it's definitely but epic rap battles should
just get chat gbt now to write the rap God
it's so funny just take all the dialogue From Any
Given character feed it into the machine and yeah
write me a Rick Grimes rap okay cool now write
me play me this guy's rap uh we should see if
chat GPT can write a real rejects reaction
video yeah see what that would look like
I miss Epic Rap Battles man I love those yeah
why did they stop did they stop making it they
just make them once in a while okay it's just
not I mean the [__] they make is really hard
to put together I understand why they do
a little like five to six videos a year
they're really hard to put together yeah
totally um I want my content ad nauseum
um real three r1k now I have oh thank you you're
the best man you're the best Matt Brown around
let's see here you've never seen IMAX before
you're doing yourself a disservice go watch
it online go watch I think watch Oppenheimer on
IMAX shoot yourself properly with the right eye
mask so you get the hype like movies that are
shot with an IMAX camera yeah um let's see here
damn I'm missing it John or are we caught up
for it are we caught up uh let me confirm if we
are caught up yeah let's check it out because
yeah we should end the stream relatively soon
still got stuff to shoot today I'm a female viewer
the Hannibal TV series is horror I've seen all the
Hannibal TV series I've seen none of the Hannibal
TV series it should is so good it's real it's
great people love it oh you got the caught up oh
my goodness we're caught up yes thank you guys
appreciate you guys always leave that like uh we
do want to watch Battle Royale oh yeah I would
love to see that all right oh I was thinking have
you I was thinking about pairing off you and Roxy
for this or are you and Tara um have you have
you seen old boy no no do you know what happens
in old boy not really I've heard vague it's been
a while since I've heard any description of old
boy I've heard vague things about it I just know
that it's really messed up but you don't know like
you don't you don't know pluck thing you know the
plot points or you don't know like the twists or
anything like that there's like a guy in a box
oh that's how the twist that's what it's about
all right that's about all I know okay because
I'm a little hesitant because the the content
around it is like messed up yeah it'll be a lot
of disclaimers for YouTube ahead of time to be
like this is all fictional yeah the ad the ad
suitability ratings will be very very awesome
um but I know for sure that last half hour
would generate the best thumbnail face needless
like yeah I think that would be I think
that um so either you and Terror or you
and uh Roxy I think for that one yeah I'd be
thrilled to let's get all two of them in here
her and koi so that way they don't shut
up and with the subtitled movie that's
gonna go even better yeah oh boy um
those guys yeah you just got to get
them a really talky movie the thing is in
that movie I I had to have a talk with them
um about the thing afterwards to give you guys
an idea like what I was saying earlier that if we
hire if we Outsource to it yes hi how are you oh I
hope you tagged that photo um I love meeting your
son at the con as well uh and what you said to me
at the con uh was insanely touching um I will not
repeat it because that's a private moment uh but
what you said was one of it was one of the most
I don't I've never gotten a compliment in person
that has truly inspired me to stay true to myself
and to keep doing what I do here so uh that was
I've never never been told anything like that in
person and I could tell it was coming from a very
real genuine place so uh thank you for being there
and uh I'm so happy I got to meet your son uh
both of you but yeah I remember I definitely I'll
never forget that conversation I do I was getting
annoyed when people were like we got to move you
guys outside because I was like what you're what
this person's telling me right now is this is the
real life what are the most like craziest things
I've ever been told personally so yeah that uh
yeah I'll never forget that so thank you I think
if we're going to react to the new evil dead I'm
so excited that I mean that's that's gonna be so
hard to edit I just know that movie's gonna be
so hard it's gonna be a very blurry reaction
yeah it's so hard to edit that yeah I wish
YouTube just didn't suppress it when uh when
you get age restricted yeah I wish they didn't
suppress the video like the disclaimer is there
like let it do its thing yeah come on yeah yeah
um ooh the call what is that no I love Korean
horror movies like Korea goes hard yeah uh I I I I
really and sometimes when we're doing that [__]
like all of us are dead like I really love that
[__] man yeah shit's fun oh all these I wonder
if all these like squid game all of us are dead
if all these you know Season twos are gonna live
up I mean I really want to see Battle Royale yeah
that's like a movie I really want to watch hearing
about that movie throughout my life yeah and so
many things compared to Battle Royale um yeah I
really want to watch that uh but uh what were we
saying before um we were talking about meeting at
WonderCon oh the thing the thing in koi and right
so normally if if like I'm not in a the video I if
the prepper people aren't editing the videos odds
are on the one editing the video now that being
said if if uh if I'm not in the video at all and
it's like a John if okay if it's John's doing the
video and I'm not in it like any any like a movie
or a show and he hands that that usually prepper
does the edit and John handles uh the notes for
the re-edit on that one and for the thing I paired
up koi and Roxy and I've already talked about them
uh Roxy took it like a champ she's like she
immediately understood it in the choir like
I really had to explain it to him it was
funny it was funny it's something I just
laugh about I just laughing about it so normally
and they've both brought that back and laughed to
me about it yeah that's good I'm glad they're
both receptive if I haven't if I'm not in it
and I'm doing a review I have to like
sync up the footage because I'm not like
I wasn't in the room when they're shooting
the reaction and it'll normally take me like
roughly like an hour to to work on a re-edit notes
you know um for for if I'm not in it and I had to
tell both of them because it wasn't a joke I was
two hours in to the to the at the re-edit of the
notes and I'm like I'm only at the 12 minutes
Mark I remember you told me that and sometimes
it is like all right I gotta talk to the editors
about this but then when I saw the raw footage and
I should have shot it too we were like yeah you
just sort of stopped talking you mentioned it to
me and then I was like I gotta go look at this and
then I I saw it I was like oh yeah if I'm sitting
here going like whoa guys pay attention to the
film you know something's wrong yeah yeah it was
a it was it was it was a very funny and it took
me over it took me over four hours to just work
on re-edit notes yeah for that yeah to the point
where sometimes I was like look I'm just gonna
edit this part and just insert this in here yeah
like reclaim I remember that and then yeah going
back to the others you're like here here's stuff
for the first 20 minutes yeah that's right out I
need you to share the first 20 minutes I need to
see if this is Flowing now yeah here's a bunch of
in-depth reworking to do and then if this works
we'll do the whole shebang yeah this is very very
funny it was it but no it's a very taxing when
it was done though I was like okay this turned
out good but I'm like no no I should never be in
a position ever again yeah now I just laugh about
it with them it was it was it was like I can't
believe this has happened they've been good sports
yeah they've maintaining they're bostonians they
know how to take it they know how to be like maybe
don't talk the whole time guys yeah sure sure
because I you gotta understand like when we're
doing these reaction something people might know
it's like one of us is taking the lead in a video
yeah and so they kind of can follow the energy
or like one of us can make the call to be like
okay I'm gonna not engage in the roofing back and
forth as much right now yeah it's only yes imagine
starting a yes and right before the credits start
rolling like like you have the best Instinct for
that and over time especially now being in in this
seat for more videos I'm like okay yeah yeah don't
don't just make this a riff Fest because it's
about being engaged with the thing they were
though in their own way yeah to credit them they
were like they were engaged and like when they
were done shooting the reaction and they came out
to the living room they were like we loved that
that movie was awesome yeah yeah yeah and so I
thought all right sweet this is cool perfect gold
mine let's go and then I was like totally they
were engaged in the way that these two are okay
oh my God Louis Berry Hannibal is a goat show
mads deserved Eminem absolutely and I wish they
would resurrect it and thank you for the Super
Chat it's always possible I don't even know what
the on my Block series is um make sure to have
two people for a blind watch along yes bring in
the comment back um half Trump half Batman make
America vigilante again I mean koi realized a
coin I realized on this live stream that we did
before uh that I think Evil Dead rise should be
a I mean like as much as it would be fun to do a
reaction to a review I watched it in the theaters
yeah absolutely like it looks like it could be a
great theater experience especially with a crowd
yeah yeah um but at the same time I'm like you
know like you kind of show up to that movie for
like this this jump scares and the gore and and
like the wild craziness yeah yeah so the mean
Spirits yeah I'm sure be I'm sure it'd be better
in the theaters than at home but I'm like I think
it would also be a great reaction where honestly
with John Wick I'm sure would have been a great
reaction yeah I feel like two and three would
be great we only throw one into them like one
but John Wick 4 has these scenes of just dialogue
and no action uh at that I'm so immersed in that
I'm like I would because you have to understand we
we can only show up to eight seconds of footage of
time yeah eight consecutive seconds at a time you
can't get all the mood sir so we need to sometimes
would be conscientious enough to like Express
a thought out loud you know Express something
out loud throw something to cut to express
something we sometimes we've got to be a little
conscientious of that and like express it you
know and uh sometimes it's hard when movies like
The Whale or Schindler's List or I'm not exactly
going to be like making a bunch of commentary yes
um jokes especially but John Wick I love just
being quiet and absorbing those moments uh and and
I I would have like yeah my preferential viewing
well I haven't seen it twice I'm like yeah I'm
glad we saw I'm glad I saw us in the theaters uh
but Evil Dead I'm like nah man it looks like it'd
be a blast I share with the audience like that
would be the one to share with the audience is
even the action in John Wick most of it I'm so
engrossed in the in the story that I'm not even
like super reactive yeah totally because I'm
just like so engaged yeah yeah and Evil Dead
is like as much as I love Evil Dead movies and the
theatrical experience that easily is like nah that
would be like such a fun reaction even still I
feel like I would still have just as much joy
in the experience uh prerninsky uh with sort of a
coin I discovered in our last live stream was that
um Batman is a liberal is a Democrat a
liberal and then the persuade is a Republican
sure sure yeah because to have the financial
Empire that Bruce Wayne does and also to keep
the facade yeah yeah he would have to be
a conservative member of his City at least
somewhat maybe a moderate conservative but yes
yeah yeah yeah direct I wanna that is though that
is the like if you think about it he is like oh
like like a a total liberal sure as Batman yeah
but uh like like I'm talking like hippie liberal
to an extent yeah I'm a Marxist Stephen yeah like
I hate the system yeah taking back the means
of production he's going against the man yeah
yeah yeah I'm gonna make my own operation and I'm
gonna protect people Wayne Enterprises billionaire
corporate yes how what are the layoffs like at
Wayne richest mofo in the most corrupt city yes
yes that's how that's why you're crazy like
I've never even thought about that until that
time we did this dream I want a comic book that
explores that that's what uh that's what would
be uh uh yeah that's why he created the baddest
so he could express those views also Aisha said
uh I saw the Devils one of her favorite Korean
horror films I've heard so much I want to see
that too yeah yeah yeah and uh to whoever asked I
have seen everything everywhere I saw it opening
night you were the first person who told me about
the movie yeah and never even knew what it was
I didn't even see the trailer for the movie
before I watched it I didn't either I just
heard that the Swiss army man guys were doing it
and it was Michelle yo and the word Multiverse
and I was just like I'm there whatever it is
I'm there I mean people talk about crying Greg
and I'm like guys to this day no movie has
broke me like that movie I was just crying
throughout and every time I've seen it it's just
there's a point where it just starts and it just
does yeah throw the Daniels in there they're my
favorite some of my favorite directors working
right now 100 I can if I need to like con like
fight back or hold back tears I can usually
do enough I was whimpering straight up just
whimpering whimpering throughout yeah I was
to the point where I was working on notes for
because I didn't edit it I I was only worked on
the re-edit when I was working on the re-edit
I was a little embarrassed when I was like
I just hear me [__] write it to the mic that's
that's a very intimate like way to look in on
yourself yeah yeah um that was a great reaction
too though and uh and uh and it suppressed my
YouTube because it's got an age restriction after
all those extra blurs and stuff that we would
have later to put uh made Smith uh uh uh Dalton
Dante uh you know there's Kingdom reactions on
the channel go check them out go check it out if
you love Kingdom watch it I don't know what the
best comment ever made is it my favorite one is
Anchorman just yeah I do love Anchorman I think
it's genius man it's hilarious all right we got
to wrap this up we're gonna do it right now uh
Lewisberry thank you so much for helping us end
our super chats experience here you deserved an
Emmy as well hope for season four you Dancy I
haven't seen it no no it's Hannibal oh oh yes
yeah dude Nancy's uh the guy oh he's doing Friday
and then uh yeah it will uh he plays that but the
guy who did hannibals in Friday 13th I'm very
excited about that oh yeah the Crystal Lake Show
Bucky Barnes but we'll have uh we'll have Jason
Bucky Barnes thank you for holding it down for
a while have fun at WrestleMania taking your son
there that's awesome yeah enjoy uh haven't seen
Tulsa King no I haven't seen any of those shows
uh I wanna I mean Yellowstone I'm sure people
have asked us to react to but I want to watch that
uh with with the misses uh Louis Berry season two
of Hannibal's season 2 finale at Hamilton two is
one greatest of all time episode yeah I I wasn't
a huge fan of season three it got a little too
got a little too artsy fartsy for me and and
everyone started talking like not people to me it
it I'm not I'm not the biggest fan of season three
um I like the show's super artistic but once
you once everyone starts sounding the same and
and talking the same and it just becomes about
communicating themes and they stop sounding like
real people now I'm like they're never now you've
become pretentious you were like perfectly RT for
me and for the art seemed perfectly violent and
thrilling but now you're just kind of bogged down
with some other [__] so if a season four ever
happens it'll be all Gore then hopefully let's
go in the other direction uh just on April
Fool's article thank you Pub and Meyer for
contributing here buddy saying Harry Styles cast
of Superman Superman Legacy to be honest I don't
hate the choice thoughts uh Harry Styles no I
mean he's already gonna be that other guy uh
Star Fox pervert uh already he's already gonna
be that guy uh I don't I feel like Harry Styles
also would be distracting and I think Harry
Styles um I think he's a charismatic actor
and while I really enjoyed him in Dunkirk
and then you know there's a good amount in
and don't worry darling but it yeah it's the movie
don't worry darling but I do think Harry Styles
I'm not saying he's incapable I love watching
actors grow I I love watching actors get better
and I I can totally see Harry Styles becoming like
an amazing actor there's not a slide against him
but there are moments in in don't worry darling
where it's like yeah he's trying to do like a
cry scene and I could tell your Force it's not
working you know that was a movie where I'm like
I I think you should have taken some smaller
roles work up your craft and then do it yeah
there it is yeah yeah but there were it's not like
he's bad throughout or something like that but I
do I do think he's got a little like I think he'd
probably be great in comedies Harry Styles I feel
like he'd probably kill it the way how Channing
Tatum was not the greatest dramatic actor and
then he started doing comedies and you're like
oh [__] this guy's like [__] amazing yeah
she's charismatic and fun and then that helped his
dramatic acting exactly yeah yeah there is there
can be a thing where it like kind of recycles
back into your dramatic work and I think here like
Fort James Franco became you know what he is now
I think when James Franco started doing comedies
like Pineapple Express Pineapple Express was the
first time I saw him in something that I was like
wow I'm really lost in the Rollies dude uh yeah
don't worry darling 44.6 female viewership really
yeah what's this let me see wouldn't it come out
uh this was November 7th 2020. what was the uh
see let me see the CPM side of it yeah it's pretty
good yeah thank you ladies for watching our videos
ladies of the reject Nation love everything
with red dragon in Hannibal Louis Berry yeah
yeah third season um becomes like the the red
dragon adaptation oh good the best of the movies
better than Hannibal I think okay is it I
don't know better than Hannibal Rising okay but
Pattinson though I'm talking not I like I don't
Pattinson proved he is a fantastic dramatic actor
though before the Batman came out yeah and anybody
who had seen those movies like no he can and
I'm going off of Harry Styles latest film police
officer he needs a while ago yeah yeah and I think
too just his profile is such that it would eclipse
the character I think it would Clash with the
character he's not an he's not in every man in the
same way I do wish that we had like some event TV
Go I mean we have Mandalorian right now but there
is something about like Wednesday was like oh this
is [__] there's something special here the water
cooler show that the globe is talking like a new
thing yeah like mandalorians returning a fresh
surprise yeah yeah but when you got something
that just comes out and takes it by storm I'm
like oh [__] you know yeah no there's like
that fun sort of like thank you for being here
Jennifer all right guys we have to head out out
ourselves really do appreciate everyone who's here
please if you haven't done so please leave a like
um and uh no I mean the live streams they
honestly like there is a weird thing about
the live streams where it makes it more fun
again to do the it's always it feels like
a great refresher to even go back and do the
regular videos you know like getting involved
in the conversation so I I really I really do
love doing these live streams a lot uh for for
perk for just like there's there's a personal
selfish benefit that I I I get in an emotional
way uh and mental Clarity way because so I
appreciate you all being here and uh thank
you all who contributed to our super chats and
I think you all contributed to the stream Labs
as well thank you guys so much uh but keep
a lookout there's a lot coming out this week
um secret Invasion Blue Beetle spider-verse
spiders I'm hearing about this hypocrisy trailer
um a Creed 3 I'm going to be doing with Andrew
you saw it in theaters right yeah yeah um don't
tell me about the IMAX but I don't want to it
actually was bad it just didn't it was one of
the movies still good it just I I wasn't like ah
this is clearly being elevated by IMAX oh that's
good to hear I was like I could have seen this in
a normal theater and felt just fine all right that
helps yeah yeah and I'd heard so much about people
being like no in IMAX and I was like yeah I mean
there's some good shots they're like it looks good
but but yeah it didn't to me beg the IMAX account
okay yeah yeah I think now too to cover a Jonathan
Majors movie is the perfect the right time SEO
yeah but every one of our little news videos
at the end and also uh Sally The Monaco was
visiting town and um we shot Pitch Perfect I'm
telling you guys right now I love the [__]
out of Pitch Perfect oh fun I I was so happy
like oh yeah I I thought it was amazing yeah
I I genuinely love the hell out of it and
I did not know it was even about acapella
oh cool that's how little I knew about I
mean I covered this stream Lab didn't I
didn't cover the latest streamline yeah yeah
it was only there's like one yeah I got the
one unless you just snuck it in right there
oh there you go up right oh thank you so much
no Chanel just said just wanted to try it out
thank you so much successful trial thank you
uh thank you for making sure the Bell works yeah
I appreciate you very much no Pitch Perfect was a
blind reaction thank you Jordan Garza thank you so
much hey don't worry you're here and at all and uh
John and Roxy shot two shot it man too so we got
a couple things that are edited uh I just gotta
make thumbnails and prep the metadata and all that
stuff which takes a while but then um and then we
got Mandalorian so it's gonna be a busy week and
also I got family visiting so I gotta also I gotta
sit down find some time for um family visiting I
want to make sure I spend plenty of time with them
um but thank you all for being here once again
uh we love you now thank you so much oh yeah no
Chanel and Jordan Garza two different people
what the hell because I thought why why why
did I forget about the stream oh he said
why I forget about the stream today guys
those fortuitous I thought you said I thought
did we both read it the same I think maybe we
both read it as stream Labs yeah yeah no why
did I forget about the stream today and then
Chanel's contributed to the streamlabs saying just
wanted to try it out it's hilarious oh thank you
thank you sir thank you so much notion thank you
both thank you and hey Jordan you you made it in
at all as long as you leave a like you are perfect
yes yes alrighty guys thanks again this is another
fun stream uh we want to do them uh regularly and
then hopefully we got a koi around for the next
one uh yeah alrighty guys well I'll chat with you
all soon much love peace and love guys thank you
ending the Stream